bien mes chers collègues je vous propose
que
le début de notre réunion de commission
et nos auditions dont je vous rappelle
qu'elles sont retransmis qu'elle est
retransmises en direct sur le site du
Sénat nous accueillons cet après-midi
monsieur le ministre Gérald Darmanin
ainsi que Monsieur Jean-François caraco
est excusé madame Caroline cailleux qui
devait être là mais qui a été obligé de
se libérer de façon urgente nous
aborderons dans un premier temps la
situation de la Nouvelle-Calédonie
singulièrement parce que le président
sueur et le président bat ainsi que
votre serviteur
nous sommes allés en Nouvelle-Calédonie
et produit un rapport d'étape mais
surtout parce que la semaine dernière
madame la Première ministre a reçu
délégation calédonienne bien sûr que les
ministres présents étaient également là
qu'il est utile nous semble-t-il de
faire un point de situation
sur la Nouvelle-Calédonie et puis enfin
nous abordons ensuite les rapports
budgétaires en réalité pour la haute
finance 2023 nous aurons l'émission
budgétaires des missions sécurité Asie
l'immigration intégration et
administration générale et territoriale
de l'État
je ne perd pas plus de temps pour
d'abord vous remercier d'être là et de
donner la parole tout de suite à
Monsieur ministre de l'Intérieur et des
Outre-mer
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre cherche Jean-François
messieurs les rapporteurs mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs très heureux de
revenir une nouvelle fois devant votre
votre commission d'abord pour ce premier
point en effet de pas Nouvelle-Calédonie
le ministre délégué complètement
autant que faire ce peu mon propos
revenir peut-être sur les quelques mois
depuis notre nomination et que nous
occupons du dossier
calédonien et notamment de la réunion
sous l'autorité de même la première
ministre qui s'est tenue la semaine
dernière
réunion qui s'est tenue qui est conforme
à la parole de l'État à l'envie des
cadeaux de voir avancer les dossiers qui
les concernent mais qui était incomplète
par le fait qu'une partie des acteurs
notamment une partie des
indépendantistes il y avait des
représentants dépendantistes à cette
réunion mais une partie des
indépendantistes ne se sont pas rendus à
notre habitation alors que le ministre
délégué pourra y revenir lors de son
déplacement avait
par notre venue et épanou réunions je
voudrais aussi évoquer l'acte qui a été
donné puisque la communiquer de presse
vous l'avez vu a été finalisé et qui a
eu le sentiment positif de l'ensemble
des présents y compris donc des
personnes qui étaient indépendantistes à
cette à cette réunion de voir confirmer
que nous allons mettre en place ce bilan
de la corde Nouméa et le dit de
décolonisation qui sera donc lancé le
commissaire à lui-même présenté le
cahier des charges qu'il a discuté avec
l'ensemble des partenaires en ce qui
concerne la Nouvelle-Calédonie il s'agit
après trois référendums vous le savez
qui ont été organisés conformément aux
accords de Matignon et de Nouméa de
pouvoir désormais installer dans un
avenir qui n'est pas celui de savoir
s'il doit si elle doit ou pas rester
française ça a été tranché par le peuple
souverain et singulièrement les les
Calédoniens eux-mêmes dans d'ailleurs
des conditions qui se sont d'ailleurs
déroulées les trois référendums sous le
quinquennat du président de la
République actuelle y compris le dernier
à quelques mois avec ce présidentiel je
voudrais ici souligner le courage qu'il
a fallu au blanc précédent au ministre
Sébastien Lecornu mais aussi au
président de la République d'organiser
ces trois consultations qui d'ailleurs
pour le troisième que j'ai géré comme
ministre de l'Intérieur en charge donc
des forces de l'ordre se sont passées
dans les meilleures conditions
démocratiques et de sécurité possible
c'est-à-dire était souligné par
l'ensemble des partenaires que nous
avons que nous avons constaté donc la
prochaine étape pour pouvoir construire
ce chemin
avec nos amis cledoniens et donc notre
déplacement monsieur le Président dire
également que notre porte est toujours
ouverte que nous regrettons évidemment
l'absence d'une partie des
indépendantistes et que nous les
associerons bien sûr à l'ensemble des
discussions que nous pourrons avoir je
sais que le ministre délégué moi-même
nous avons reçu Monsieur Mapou par
exemple mais continue à avoir des
échanges téléphoniques avec en attendant
de se voir sur place et ils emmener
notre sujet indépendamment des sujets
institutionnels qui sont évidemment
extrêmement importants au lendemain
peut-être une révision constitutionnelle
puisqu'il faudra bien tirer les
conclusions de la Constitution qui
aujourd'hui s'arrête bien évidemment au
troisième référendum et il y a un
nouveau une nouvelle situation que qui
est créée par ce troisième référendum
qui confirme l'attachement avec les
Denis à l'unité de la République de voir
comment nous construisons évidemment les
choses ensemble mais il y a aussi tous
les autres sujets extrêmement importants
le nickel en premier mais pas que le
nickel que va détailler le ministre
délégué pour mettre la
Nouvelle-Calédonie dans dans l'avenir et
de ne pas parler que de choses qui
relèvent de l'institutionnel voilà en
quelques mots monsieur le Président je
serai peut-être à Jean-François cadenco
si vous souhaitez le soin de compléter
mes propos
sur le président monsieur le ministre
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
évidemment rien rien à simplement à
ajouter ou à confirmer ce que dit le
ministre de l'Intérieur d'abord j'ai
noté moi que ça s'était passé dans une
bonne ambiance les gens étaient plutôt
détendus les gens étaient
à chaleureux mais se parler logiquement
il y avait quelques indépendantistes
quand même
qui était là et les tours de table ont
été très sérieux confirmés aussi parce
que ça a été dit à plusieurs reprises
que chacun reconnaissait que le choix du
président de la République et du
gouvernement tenir le référendum mois de
décembre était un choix courageux et
j'allais dire déterminant que se
passerait-il sans être référendum
maintenant chacun se le poser la
question et donc tout le monde a
ressenti que ce qui avait été fait avait
été bien fait le deuxième sujet je
voudrais mettre en avant ni se lève ok
c'est le nickel tout le monde dit on a
des problèmes de fiscalité des problèmes
de recettes pour le territoire tout ça
c'est nickel la situation où vous êtes
rendu là-bas un certain nombre n'est pas
bonne n'est pas bonne dans le sud
l'usine de
n'est pas bonne à Nouméa n'est pas bonne
dans le Nord donc il nous faut réfléchir
le ministère des Finances et mission à
l'intérieur et moi-même essayons de
trouver la bonne formule de travail à
Paris là-dessus bien évidemment il faut
que le ministère des Finances soit dans
le coup il faut qu'il y ait un
spécialiste qui accompagne tout ça parce
qu'à la fois des questions techniques et
des questions j'allais dire
capitalistiques et tout ça à l'arrivée
on fait quand même une question
politique donc prenons un peu de temps
mais le sujet est tout à fait essentiel
l'autre dernier point que je voudrais
mettre en avant
c'est que tout le monde a bien dit il y
a les questions institutionnelles à
régler d'une certaine manière et il y a
le reste profitons pour mettre
pour que l'État aide cette société
qu'elle est donnienne à se mettre en
route après ces deux référendum une fois
qui a été confirmé l'appartenance à la
République il y a un certain nombre de
sujets qui sont là on a dit les
questions exceptionnelles les questions
d'égale pour le reprendre ce qui a été
acté comme conclusion question
institutionnelle égalité des chances et
cohésion sociale développement
économique emploi grands investissement
nickel souveraineté énergétique qui vont
un petit peu ensemble souvent une telle
alimentaire alimentaire et foncier
valeur
identité commune et réconciliation et
régionales voilà le calendrier le
ministre l'a dit démarrera après
préparation
par le haut-commissaire en ce moment
même et préparation du voyage du Midi
Armanet moi-même et le ministre est là
pour lancer ces groupes de travail après
un nouveau contact bien sûr avec les
parties qui n'étaient pas là à Paris
mais le contact moi je n'ai pas eu
depuis
m'interdit avant que au commissaire
fasse son travail plutôt au commissaire
à
retisser ses liens
mais je dirais que j'ai bon espoir que
le voyage de 8 jours soit productif soit
productif et que ça enclenche un
processus dont
on s'est dit que ça serait bien que ça
arrive au bout à la Miami 2023
tout le monde converger alors ça fait
8-10 mois c'est à la fois long et pas
long mais puis dis-moi nécessaire même
si le président
alors peut-être la parole en rapporteur
Monsieur Jean-Pierre
merci monsieur le Président et messieurs
les ministres
nous sommes tous
dédiés à la recherche d'un accord en
Nouvelle-Calédonie
c'est nous pouvons nous Sénat et
commissions des lois avec le président
buffet et Jean-Pierre Sueur ainsi
qu'ervé Marseille et apporter une
contribution nous en serons évidemment
très heureux
j'espère
qu'après la rencontre informel de Paris
la semaine dernière sans les
indépendantistes votre déplacement
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur et
des Outre-mer avec monsieur le ministre
délégué à Nouméa
permettra de renouer le dialogue
parce que pour l'instant
c'est
une situation
où une des parties
n'est pas présente dans les discussions
je crois que tout partageons la même
conviction il n'y a pas de solution
durable
en Nouvelle-Calédonie sans un accord il
peut y avoir une solution de l'État une
solution unilatérale qui soit une
solution durable ça n'assurerait pas la
coexistence des Calédoniens entre
il n'y a pas non plus de majorité à
Paris au Parlement
sans un accord et notamment pas de
majorité au Congrès possible
pour une révision constitutionnelle donc
l'enjeu il est bien là c'est de réussir
et c'est votre défi à nouer non pas ce
dialogue mais d'abord ce dialogue et
ensuite ce trilogue si j'ose dire état
n'en indépendantiste indépendantiste
pour créer des solutions durables les
solutions sont jamais définitives on est
dans l'ordre du politique mais au moins
qu'elle puisse durer aussi longtemps que
les accords de Matignon et de Nouméa
pour assurer la stabilité et le
développement de la nouvelle
il y a un paradoxe et c'est ce sur quoi
posera portera mon unique question
vous avez donné depuis l'élection
présidentielle le sentiment de vous
hâter avec lenteur
j'espère que cela permettra tout de même
comme dans la fable
d'atteindre la ligne d'arrivée d'un
accord ce que nous souhaitons tous
mais cette lenteur
qu'elle soit voulue ou liée à un certain
nombre de péripéties
est-ce que elle est réellement
compatible avec le calendrier que vous
avez en tête
et très serré ce calendrier monsieur le
ministre délégué après avoir paru hésité
la confirmer en nouvelle
qui a des données depuis Nouméa un
référendum comme l'a annoncé monsieur
Lecornu votre prédécesseur sur cette
partie de vos compétences
d'ici la fin du premier semestre 2023 il
y a quand même un compte à rebours
oui consultation en Nouvelle-Calédonie
avait mal compris il n'y aura pas de
référendum en Nouvelle-Calédonie vous
n'avez pas prévu ça mais vous allez
pouvoir me répondre alors c'est nouveau
avant la fin du premier semestre 2023 ce
référendum devrait être précédé d'un
accord
cet accord
certainement devra être suivi d'une
révision constitutionnelle est-ce que ce
calendrier tenable et est-ce que après
l'ami 2023 vous pensez pouvoir tenir
aussi le calendrier prévu pour les
élections régionales en
Nouvelle-Calédonie c'est ça ma question
parce qu'au fond on met la pression sur
le calendrier on pose des espèces
d'ultimatum et pour l'instant tout le
monde n'est pas réuni à la table de
négociation
merci cette question monsieur qui est
sur oui merci beaucoup monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues je dois vous dire
que je garde un excellent souvenir enfin
souvenir marquant de cette de cette
délégation à laquelle a participé
monsieur le Président François Noël
buffet
Philippa et moi-même en
Nouvelle-Calédonie avant l'été où nous
avons passé beaucoup de temps 42
auditions
pour entendre avec une certaine humilité
comme on dit là-bas dans la coutume ce
qui était dit et nous savons eu le
sentiment c'est ce que dit notre rapport
d'étape que vous avez lu et ce que dira
encore plus précisément le rapport
définitif nous avons eu le sentiment
qu'en dépit des oppositions il y avait
des possibilités de rapprochement parce
que les différents leaders de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie se connaissent très
bien
et que finalement il y a le discours les
postures et puis il y a aussi ces films
mystérieux qui font que petit à petit
les choses peuvent évoluer
à cet égard je reprendrai je suis tort
tout à la corde d'ailleurs c'est pas
hasard avec ce que vient de dire
Philippa et je dois dire que nous avons
connu
des moments difficiles au mois de
juillet
et puis encore récemment
parce que il y a eu
Jean-François Carenco ne vous
connaissons depuis longtemps
et nous connaissons votre sens du
dialogue et même d'être empathique avec
les personnes avec qui vous parlez on
commence par des compliments mais vous
savez quand même dit lors de votre
dernier déplacement j'ai la les le verbe
devant une délégation le matin il n'y
aura pas de référendum de projet en
juillet ou septembre 2023
on peut comprendre que c'est d'autres
moi que juillet septembre enfin les gens
ont compris qu'il y aurait pas de
référendum et puis l'après-midi devant
d'autres interlocuteurs vous avez dit je
cite ce référendum de projet il a
toujours été question qu'il y ait lieu
il y a aucun sujet là-dessus le
référendum de projet c'est une évidence
bon je vois votre sens du dialogue et ça
je ne le conteste pas simplement la
réalité chers amis c'est que comme l'a
dit d'ailleurs Philippe Bas il n'est pas
possible qu'il y ait un référendum à
court terme
mais non mais parce que il ne peut y
avoir de référendum spécifiques à ce
territoire que si on change la
Constitution or si vous pensez que les
conditions politiques sont réunies pour
que le Sénat et l'Assemblée vote à même
texte qui serait soumis au Congrès d'ici
la fin 2023 je crois que c'est quelque
peu utopiques
deuxièmement je vais
peut-être aborder un sujet
après tout Michel Rocard et ce n'est pas
un hasard si je parle de lui dans ce
débat disait qu'il faut parler vrai
je dois dire qu'il y a un événement sur
lequel je voulais vous
interroger qui pèse quand même lourd
dans le dossier
la nomination au sein du gouvernement de
Madame Sonia ba caisse
nous pensons nous avons dit et écrit et
écrit encore récemment qui nous
paraissait que pour avancer le
gouvernement devait être impartial c'est
une position on peut considérer que le
gouvernement doit être partial mais
jusque là et notamment pour le troisième
référendum le gouvernement a tenu à une
certaine impartialité c'est nécessaire
si on veut que les points de vue se
rapprochent
or dès lors que vous savez dans le
gouvernement à vos côtés une personne
tout à fait estimable nous l'avons
rencontré mais qui est le fer de lance
de l'une des parties et qui déclare
parce que j'ai ici à votre disposition
ces déclarations à Nouvelle-Calédonie
première
déclaration très ferme que naturellement
eux elle sera membre du gouvernement ce
qui ne l'empêchera pas s'il y a deux
parties qui dialogues d'être clairement
dans l'une des parties
alors là on ne comprend pas très bien et
vous savez très bien je ne vous la
prends pas que les indépendantistes
n'ont pas été insensibles à la situation
ainsi créée
donc je ne demande rien il y a votre
collègue du gouvernement mais simplement
je ne demande même pas qu'elle le
démissionne de son poste de président de
la région sud
conformément à ce qu'on fait certains de
vos collègues du gouvernement c'est son
livre choix mais il me semble que si le
gouvernement
est impartial veut être impartial se dit
impartial de manière à être efficace
et bien il faut peut-être régler cette
question peut-être que l'intéresser peut
faire des déclarations en disant qu'elle
se retire du dossier qu'elle ou qu'elle
fait preuve d'un partialité vous
comprenez nous avons même vu comment les
choses se sont passées lors de la
réunion à Paris où les indépendantistes
n'étaient pas présents puisque monsieur
l'allée que nous avons nous-mêmes reçus
bien sûr nous avons reçu tous les
interlocuteurs nous a dit qu'il était là
en tant que président de la province des
îles qui demandent le décès de tout à
fait naturelle et donc nous pensons
qu'il y a là peut-être un préalable levé
je ne demande pas de me pardonner d'être
direct et de dire les choses comme je
les ressens après la levée de manière à
ce que nous le souhaitons vraiment
lorsque tous les deux vous irez à
nouveau en Nouvelle-Calédonie à Nouméa
j'espère que les groupes de travail
seront acceptés par les deux parties que
vous réussissiez à ce que
par un dialogue avec une des parties
ambilatérales par l'autre partie en
bilatérale ensuite j'espère entrer
latérale on puisse avancer et je vais
terminer comment avancer il me semble
que la question du référendum est un
chiffon rouge qui ne sert à rien puisque
il est impossible de le faire à court
terme
il me semble que la question du régime
électoral est une vraie question mais il
faudra du temps de la précaution pour
arriver à avancer parce qu'on peut pas
rester dans cette situation là il me
semble qu'il faut trouver le chemin
en partant vous savez pendant vous savez
bien il y a eu les accords de Paris les
accords de Nouméa on a pu les critiquer
ils ont permis une certaine paix
vivre ensemble je crois qu'il faut
repartir sur un chemin pour vivre
ensemble peut-être en partant des
réalités économiques sociales
culturelles coutumière
[Musique]
et en même temps il faudra des signes
pour marquer l'autonomie la spécificité
je ne sais comment dire de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie par exemple la
question de l'autodétermination a
toujours été présente dans le processus
il me semble qu'entre ces deux
points il y a un chemin sans doute
étroit mais je souhaite de tout cœur je
vous le dis à tous les deux je souhaite
de tout cœur que vous puissiez avancer
sur ce chemin
merci monsieur le ministre
oui c'est la question de monsieur le
Président BA de on s'est athénot
reprenant ainsi le ver de Hugo je vois
pas très bien comment on aurait pu se
rater autrement parce que sauf si vous
considérez que
on aurait dû organiser un déplacement du
ministre de moi-même entre les élections
présidentielles etatives je rappelle que
ils sont présentées au mois de mai que
le gouvernement était formé une semaine
après ce qui est bien logique puis la
campagne des législatives il aurait été
bizarre d'entreprendre des discussions
alors même que les canoniens eux-mêmes
choisissaient leur représentant à
l'Assemblée nationale donc nous sommes
arrivés fin juin nous avons décidé
d'envoyer le ministre caraco tout début
septembre après deux conseils de défense
organisés par le chef de l'État sur la
question canadienne nous avons
nous-mêmes reçus d'ailleurs à Paris à sa
tante d'interlocuteur qu'elle est devenu
un dès début septembre le ministre est
allé une semaine et nous avons organisé
après les invitations lancées à la venue
du ministre cette journée de travail au
mois de phase 2 journées de travail
puisque ça a duré deux jours au mois
d'octobre donc en fait je vois pas très
bien comme on aurait fait qu'on aurait
pu faire plus vite sauf à bousculer les
demandes même des cadoniens qui sont
indépendantistes ou non indépendantistes
qui disait on attend la campagne
législative se termine et on ne veut
surtout pas accélération de calendrier
peut-être que vous
incluez le moment entre décembre le
référendum et l'élection présidentielle
c'est une autre question qui se pose je
rappelle qu'à l'époque le fnks en
premier avait dit qu'il ne discuterait
pas avec des représentants de l'étape
tant que le Président de la République
n'était pas connu ce qui est d'ailleurs
une position assez logique il faut bien
l'avouer puisque la fin de la période
des accords c'est peut-être ce qui nous
différencie monsieur le Président sueur
de Matignon et de et de Nouméa puisque
ce qui était prévu c'est trois
référendum mais on a terminé ce
troisième référendum créer une nouvelle
situation à étudier c'est l'objet de nos
discussions elle ne pouvait pas
s'engager avec un président de la
République qui n'était pas à coup sûr
Emmanuel Macron et chacun l'aurait sans
doute contesté si monsieur le président
parapluie qui avait préemonté des
arbitrages qui engagé bien au-delà de
son quinquennat donc je vois pas très
bien ce qu'on aurait pu faire de plus
rapide vu le calendrier imposé par le
par les temps et d'ailleurs le fait que
nous retournions dès le mois de novembre
en Nouvelle-Calédonie démontre me
semble-t-il que au contraire on
considère que chaque mois est une
avancée bien sûr dans l'absence des des
indépendantistes moi je veux aussi
souligner quelque chose que vous n'avez
pas fait mais comme vous suivez le
dossier
vous le savez pertinemment peut-être pas
tous ceux qui nous écoutent le FLNKS est
divisé
incontestablement il a un congrès
politique qui arrive et il a souhaité ne
pas régler ses problèmes avant le
congrès du fnks nous avons justement
fait le choix de ne pas procrastiner
pour d'autre part et de ne pas encore
attendre trouver une excuse pour ne pas
avancer par ailleurs une partie du fnks
conteste à validité vous savez bien du
3e référendum partant du principe qu'il
pourrait demander l'Assemblée générale
des Nations unies de saisir un tribunal
qui pourrait remettre en cause la vérité
de ce référendum et une partie des
conseils de ceux qui contestent la
possibilité de valider
totalement ce référendum ils disent si
vous allez à Paris alors vous validerez
le fait que vous rendez légitime ce
troisième référendum et ils nous disent
nous tant qu'on n'est pas sur que les
Nations Unies ne valide pas ce
référendum on ne veut pas discuter donc
ça vous amène à fa 23 pour faire très
très vite pour nous ce n'est évidemment
pas un calendrier acceptable
parce que les Calédoniens par trois fois
on choisit de rester dans la République
après des élections me semble-t-il
clairement
disputés comme on dit
démocratique et d'ailleurs je crois que
les Nations Unies vous le savez bien
n'ont rien eu à redire et même le C 24 a
considéré que nous avons tenu bien
évidemment tous les engagements
internationaux de la France et bien sûr
le droit à l'autodétermination en
premier lieu qui reste toujours dans
notre droit d'ailleurs donc je pense que
il y a un sujet qui est un sujet
difficile pour les indépendantistes
c'est la première fois depuis très
longtemps qui ne sont pas dans une
situation où justement il y a un
référendum d'autodétermination certains
à quelques mois ou quelques années près
et je pense que ça crée une difficulté
bien sûr dans le camp indépendantiste
nous devons respecter nous devons
l'accompagner nous devons montrer notre
porte est toujours ouverte il ne s'agit
du billet absolument personne on est
prêt à discuter de plein de sujets
évidemment qui concernent la
Nouvelle-Calédonie sa forme
institutionnelle la façon fonctionne son
corps électoral la façon dont on doit
avoir l'avenir on ne peut pas faire
comme si ces trois référendum n'avaient
pas dit par trois fois que les
Calédoniens voulaient rester dans la
République française parce qu'on du coup
aussi on n'avait pas organisé ces
réunions si on nous organisait pas ses
déplacements vous nous diriez à juste
titre en tout cas pour une partie de
l'hémicycle du Sénat mais alors chers
amis voudraient respectez pas la voix
des Calédoniens qu'on choisit la France
et qui par ailleurs souhaite un avenir
et qui se pose désormais plein de
questions sur le sur le logement sur la
santé sur l'énergie sur le sur le nickel
sur le travail sur l'environnement
géopolitique et d'ailleurs vous le savez
très bien d'autres grandes puissances
nous regardent pour savoir si nous
sommes capables de pouvoir être fort
dans ce territoire particulier français
là où je vous suis pas messieurs mais
peut-être que cette commission justement
permet de lever son aiguilles n'est pas
prévu de nouveau référendum
pourquoi d'ailleurs aurait-il lieu
puisque puisque
non mais il n'y a pas de prévu de
nouveaux référendum dans les mois qui
viennent dans les années qui viennent il
faut évidemment qu'on peut discuter de
tout c'est le principe des discussions
mais la Nouvelle-Calédonie a fait le
choix de la République il y a
effectivement plusieurs questions qui se
posent pour savoir si nous avons la
possibilité de les faire dans le cadre
du Parlement actuel vous avez
parfaitement raison le changement
constitutionnel et notamment je l'ai dit
moi-même l'article 77 et son alinéa 4 me
semble-t-il de la Constitution la
question du corps électoral qui va se
poser puisque nous avons les
Provinciales qui sont à organiser mais
il est évident que l'année de travail
qui évoquait le ministre délégué ne
comprend pas un référendum il comprend
le rendu me semble-t-il des groupes de
travail et nous l'espérons toutes et
tous des bilatérales des trilatérales
conclusifs qui nous permet de faire un
chemin et pourquoi pas monsieur le
Président sûr vous avez parfaitement
raison voir quelles sont les symboles
quels sont les politiques que nous
pouvons imaginer être soit des
compétences partagées soit des
compétences entières de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie vous savez d'ailleurs
que c'est un endroit le plus
décentralisé qui existe dans la
République puisque hormis à faire
régalienne on ne va pas très bien ce
qu'on pourrait les centraliser davantage
mais nous pourrions ouvrir des voies et
des chemins c'est-à-dire pour ça que
nous continuons à discuter bien
évidemment l'axe indopacifique évoqué
par président de la République nous
montre peut-être d'ailleurs un de un de
ces chemins de définir ce que nous
voulons pour la Nouvelle-Calédonie et
quelle est sa grande place dans la
réplique française alors là où j'ai
moins compris monsieur présidentiel
c'est quand vous dites l'État doit être
neutre si l'état devait avoir un
impartialité particulière dans
l'organisation des référendums une fois
que ces référendums sont établis et
qu'ils ont eu lieu dans des élections
disputées et j'ai constaté que vous ne
remettiez pas en cause ni dans votre
prise de parole ni dans le rapport
d'étape que vous avez fourni que j'ai
attentivement et j'attends évidemment
avec le musée votre rapport définitif on
s'inspira bien évidemment de vos
conseils de vos recommandations
l'État ne peut pas rester indéfiniment
indifférent au sort de
Nouvelle-Calédonie et constaté tous
ensemble désormais que la question a été
tranchée monsieur le Président
non parce que je vous ai je vous ai je
vous ai écouté mais attendez on laisse
terminer le ministre et donc paroles le
troisième référendum a été a été a été
fait a été organisé et pas troisième
fois les cadeniers en quelques années on
dit qu'il souhaitait rester français on
va pas ad vitam monsieur presenseur
interdire à tout calédonien de
participer au gouvernement de son pays
parce qu'il faudrait que nous ayons une
position
là encore ad vitam d'un partialité ce
serait de drôle de citoyens que les
citoyens de Nouvelle-Calédonie si on
disait tout le monde peut être membre du
gouvernement sauf ceux qui sont
calédoniens ce serait pas vraiment être
pleinement dans la République française
donc je crois que votre remarque sur
Sonya bac S elle n'est d'ailleurs pas en
charge de l'outre-mer elle n'est pas en
charge de la Nouvelle-Calédonie c'est la
place d'une citoyenne française qui
présente la République sont proposition
de Premier ministre a répondu
favorablement à servir son pays et je
crois que il y a pas de contestation de
ce point d'ailleurs je voudrais vous
dire pour avoir été très en contact avec
les indépendantistes pour les avoir
entendus pour ceux qui sont venus y
compris monsieur l'Allier à la Réunion
que nous avons organisé pour avoir reçu
Monsieur Mapou lui-même pour avoir lu
les tracts ou les communiqués de presse
soit pour dire qu'il venait soit pour
dire qu'il ne venait plus en aucun
manière madame bacaisse a été cité
jamais à aucun moment et d'ailleurs je
voudrais faire remarquer que si notre
porte est toujours ouverte la parole
donnée compte énormément partout et
s'agirament Nouvelle-Calédonie on a été
un peu étonné avec le ministre délégué
qui connaît bien le territoire que vous
savez puisqu'il a servi dans d'autres
fonctions il pourra compléter évidemment
les propos que cette parole donnée pas
été tenu de pouvoir venir à Paris alors
il y a peut-être aussi d'autres sujets
notamment des sujets de peur parce que
vous savez que ceux qui à l'époque sont
venus discuter avec le gouvernement ont
connu les affres de la violence c'est
aussi à nous de les rassurer sans aucune
espèce de porte reste ouverte mais je
veux aussi dire à présent sûr que une
fois que le troisième référendum était
organisé la question n'est pas de savoir
quand est-ce qu'on va faire un quatrième
référendum
d'indépendance potentielle
mais de bien considérer que l'État
désormais n'a plus de neutralité à voir
mais à aider à Nouvelle-Calédonie aller
vers le chemin qu'on choisit lesquels
deiens maintenant vous avez posé une
remarque vous avez dit le taux
détermination était présent dans les
accords de Matignon et de Nouméa mais
l'autonométermination est pas nature
présente dans tout temps dans notre
fonctionnement constitutionnel et il
n'est pas du tout
question de l'animé et de dire que plus
jamais la question ne se posera on verra
bien comme les choses se passeront il
est évident qu'elles ne peuvent pas se
passer dans dans un temps très court
dans un moyen terme puisque par
définition je crois que ce serait pas
respecté le vote et le processus de
Matignon donc pour résumer il n'y aura
pas dans notre calendrier à référendum à
organiser dans les mois qui viennent ça
ne veut pas dire qu'on n'aura pas un
jour sur le projet qu'on a pour la
Nouvelle-Calédonie mais ce n'est pas
dans l'année qui évoquait monsieur le
ministre qu'un oui il faudrait faire
vous le savez tous une réforme
constitutionnelle pour adapter notamment
la question du corps électoral qui se
pose par le Conseil d'État par les
juristes européens par nous-mêmes on le
voit bien que la finalité pour lequel on
a fait ses dispositions exorbitantes du
droit commun était conditionné par le
juge constitutionnel lui-même à des buts
qui sont maintenant
atteints c'est j'ose dire l'organisation
troisième homme on sait tous que c'est
une question extrêmement délicate par
ailleurs et donc elle ne mérite pas
d'être traitée c'est parce que vous avez
fait c'est parce que nous faisons d'un
revers de la main il y aura-t-il une
majorité au 3/5 pour voter ce genre de
de référendum de
modification constitutionnelle
moi je suis ni prison de la République
ni membre du Parlement réunion congrès
donc cette question de m'appartient pas
notre travail c'est de proposer et nous
le souhaitons en union de penser et
d'esprit total avec indépendance on est
bien tout à fait d'accord avec vous
c'est notre devoir que trouver ce chemin
il n'est pas facile mais en tout cas
c'est plein de volonté qu'on le fait et
dans l'écoute de nos citoyens de
nouvelles chédonies qui ont choisi
l'indépendance mais aussi pour tous ceux
qui n'ont pas choisi l'indépendance et
qui ont été majoritaires dans les trois
référendums que nous avons constaté je
constate d'ailleurs les gens terminerai
par là avant que Jean-François ne
complète que tous les maires puisque
vous dites qu'on veut s'appuyer sur les
mers vous avez bien raison organiser les
opérations électorales du troisième
référendum y compris les
indépendantistes ce qui renforce l'idée
que ce référendum a été organisé y
compris par ceux qui pourtant vous le
savez bien revendiquer l'indépendance
c'est l'endroit le plus strict que nous
respectons profondément bien sûr en
vertu des anciens et de leur engagement
mais on peut constater qu'il ma mère de
melkadoni quel que soit son son sa
conviction
est refuser de l'organiser
j'ai mis peut-être deux compléments 1 un
témoignage je suis ministre délégué
auprès de Gérald Darmanin tout comme
Sonia baquet je confirme que le crédit
n'est pas son sujet à Paris c'est clair
c'est précis voilà après le président de
la Province Sud et d'ailleurs lors de la
réunion
le commissaire du cinéma
dans qu'elle fait bien attention je veux
témoigner de ça elle fait très attention
parce qu'elle sait bien que sinon ça
crée des problèmes et puis parce que
c'est son sentiment très simplement
deuxième sujet sur les calendriers je
confirme que
dire on va faire comme ci comme ci comme
ça et pas et pas opportun il y a
ministre l'a dit il y a un sujet c'est
les Provinciales il y a une
nécessité c'est après de
constitutionnaliser les choses et ça ça
suppose effectivement une réforme de la
Constitution française ça suppose
l'accord au 3/5 du Parlement donc soyez
rassurés même si on n'est pas envie on a
besoin de vous monsieur
sénateur et et idem bien sûr au
Parlement donc tout ça est assez lié
après je veux dire que ce qu'on entend
contient indépendantiste comme côté
loyaliste et de termes d'ailleurs c'est
tout le monde souhaite le retour de
l'État avec une seule ligne rouge c'est
l'appartenance à la République après
voyons comment elle se traduit dans les
faits et c'est
libre savoir comment elle va se traduire
libres par les discussions mais moi je
veux témoigner que ce soit les
indépendantistes les loyalistes tout le
monde appelle
au retour de l'État par retour parce que
c'est pas bien pour ce qui s'est passé
j'ai mal à la profondement du rôle de
l'État pour amener sur ce chemin pour
amener sur ce chemin donc moitié de
personnes je pense qu'il y a comme vous
une solution consensuelle mais ne nous
pressons pas nous disons pas des choses
trop trop brutales on verra évidemment
et moi-même là-bas comment ça se déroule
comment ça se déroule je me suis assuré
d'une seule chose avant le 28 Février 28
octobre c'est qu'il nous accueillerait
tous c'est ce que j'ai dit au ministre
avant la réunion ils sont prêts nous
accueillir au delà les sons se nouer les
choses laissons se nouer les choses
merci Monsieur battre la parole merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre merci de vos réponses qui a une
exception près était tout à fait
complète
par rapport aux questions que nous
avions posé mais
cette ce dialogue que nous avons me
paraît clair et concret et nous
cherchons tous à aller dans la direction
d'un accord donc c'est important que
nous parlions avec franchise
monsieur le ministre par la réponse que
vous avez apporté sur les référendum de
projet vous n'ignorez pas vous ne pouvez
ignorer que vous avez fait une annonce
très importante elle sera comprise comme
telle par tous les partenaires du
dossier
calédonien et personne ne s'y trompera
c'est une décision majeure sans doute la
plus importante annoncée par le
gouvernement
depuis sa formation ce qui concerne le
dossier qu'elle est donnien
et je dois dire en ce qui me concerne
que je trouve que ce renoncement et sage
qui lui était extrêmement difficile de
forcer le passage pour organiser
référendum de projet à la date où il
avait été initialement prévu donc vous
donner un petit peu d'oxygène
ce qui ne vous empêche pas comme vous
l'avez dit d'envisager à l'issue d'un
accord qui se suit celui-ci soit
consacré par un vote des
Calédoniens il y a je disais tout à
l'heure une petite exception
au caractère exhaustif de vos réponses
c'est
le sujet des élections provinciales
en 2024 vous n'avez pas souhaité
répondre sur la possibilité de tenir à
l'échéance prévue ces élections et à
vrai dire monsieur le ministre je ne
veux pas vous pousser dans vos
retranchements je pense que vous avez
raison de ne pas vous engager car tant
qu'on peut espérer les tenir à la bonne
date grâce à une négociation qui se
passerait dans de bonnes conditions
alors il est normal de ne pas envisager
qu'elles soient différée mais aussi
simplement sur un point s'il était
possible de lever la difficulté de
calendrier liée au référendum de projets
qui avait été annoncé et confirmé par le
gouvernement est en revanche beaucoup
plus difficile
de reculer cette échéance des élections
provinciales ça crée quand même pour la
négociation
une exigence parce que ces élections
provinciales pourront difficilement se
dérouler sans que la question du corps
électoral ne soit ne soit tranchée voilà
les réactions que je voulais formuler
après vos propos à l'un et à l'autre
merci monsieur Sueur dernière question
puis après on passera
je considère aussi que cette date
monsieur Darmanin monsieur le ministre
du 2 novembre est importantes parce que
tout à l'heure on entendant référendum
référendum référendum il adore réalité
différente il y a eu trois référendum
une contestons nullement leur existence
le résultat
il y a l'annonce de Monsieur le Cornu en
vertu de laquelle il y aurait un
référendum deux projets d'ici la fin
2023 et vous venez d'annoncer le 2
novembre à Paris qu'il n'aurait pas ou
alors nous n'avons pas compris mais je
crois que nous avons bien compris de
référendum de projet et moi je vous en
félicite parce que je pense que c'est
pas la peine de maintenir comme ça en
l'air une espèce de choses dont on sait
tous qu'elle ne pourra pas arriver
ça dégage l'horizon
pour
reprendre les discussions je le crois et
vous l'avez dit tous les deux sur une
pluralité de sujet de manière à
peut-être recréer un climat qui permet
d'aborder sans qu'on fixe d'échéances
particulières cette question électorale
du corps électoral qui est quand même
divisible et qui ne pourra être réglé
que si on crée un climat
favorable à ce qu'elle soit réglée vous
voyez qu'on est totalement sur la même
ligne et nous savions vos propos
merci Monsieur le Ministre oui peut-être
très rapidement je veux dire trois
choses très claires pour bien que tout
le monde soit bien
dans le même la même compréhension si il
doit y avoir référendum il ne peut pas
s'agir d'un référendum je sais que vous
le savez c'est pour tout le monde
comprenne
d'autodétermination cela a été réglé par
les trois référendums
d'autodétermination qui ont été
organisés sous le quinquennat du
président de la République le ministre
le Cornu a évoqué un référendum de
projet il est tout à fait possible que
ce référendum de projet pour savoir quel
est le nouveau statut quelles nouvelles
politiques dans la République puisse se
tenir nous disons avec le ministre
caraco mais comme vous que ce serait me
semble-t-il comme vous l'avez très bien
dit difficile de constater qu'il peut se
tenir dans l'année qui vient puisque
deuxième évidence après avoir dit que
c'était pas un référendum
d'auto-détermination et de projet ce que
nous souhaitons toutes et tous c'est que
le mode politique de fonctionnement de
mécanique est suit du consensus le plus
rapproché possible pas celui du tranchet
entre le oui et le nom entre deux camps
politiques celui du consensus politique
et celui et même j'allais dire surtout
mais même les non indépendantistes l'ont
souligné d'ailleurs à la première
ministre doit être recherché par l'État
par les bilatérales par les trilatérales
et par des déplacements et par de
l'écoute et par de l'envie de travailler
en commun pour la Nouvelle-Calédonie
bien évidemment et plus on pourra
s'approcher d'une méthode consensuelle
moi on fera des choses clivées dans un
temps trop court qui nous ferait quant à
agoniser les uns ou les autres
mieux on se portera si on arrive à aller
vers le consensus et il ne nous apparaît
pas possible aujourd'hui mais comme vous
venez de le dire qu'on puisse se mettre
d'accord sur tous les sujets qui
concerneraient ce projet pour le veille
qui est donné dans un temps aussi court
troisième sujet
est-ce qu'il faut faire une réforme
constitutionnelle elle est obligatoire
si j'ose dire vu comment rédiger notre
Constitution mais ce n'est pas moi qui
convoque les référendums qui convoquent
les congrès ce n'est pas moi qui les
votent non plus donc notre travail à
nous c'est de d'amener ce chemin vers la
réforme qui pourrait être acceptée par
toutes et tous dans cette réforme
acceptée par toutes et tous il y a une
double question la question de faut-il
donner des compétences supplémentaires à
la Nouvelle-Calédonie à son gouvernement
à ses provinces à son fonctionnement
c'est une possibilité voilà laquelle ou
lesquels dans quelles conditions est-ce
que ça peut faire partie du consensus
qu'on dessine pour respecter un certain
nombre évidemment de demande de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie et notamment des
personnes qui sont indépendantistes mais
aussi des Calédoniens qui ne sont pas
indépendantistes mais qui veulent
davantage encore de compétences et
deuxièmement doit-on revenir sur le
corps électoral je rappelle trois listes
électorales en Belgique
électorale générale quand il vote pour
l'élection présidentielle Yanis
électorale pour les Provinciales et
sélectorales pour un éventuel référendum
la liste référendaire donc et vous savez
bien que la situation aujourd'hui est
née elle est très difficile puisque il y
a d'un côté les indépendantistes qui ne
veulent pas qu'on touche vous le savez
bien à ce corps un peu figé du corps
électoral pour une partie de ces
électorat et le parti de gens qui disent
mais il y a des gens qui sont depuis de
nombreuses années de volcaniques qui
peuvent toujours pas voter y compris
pour choisir leur dirigeants de la
province et donc la question subsidiaire
à laquelle monsieur bat souhaite
m'interroger tout en comprenant que je
ne lui réponds pas
fait que il y a la question évidemment
des Provinciales qui doivent se tenir
elles doivent se tenir ses provinciales
la question c'est avec quelques
électorales je crois qu'on est là pour
le coup monsieur bah vous le savez bien
on a encore un petit peu de temps avant
de pouvoir décider de tout cela d'abord
il y a des sénatoriales qui vont se
dérouler en Nouvelle-Calédonie je crois
que c'est renouvelable me semble-t-il
c'est intéressant par nature et
deuxièmement on va quand même pas faire
le voyage avant d'y aller donc moi je ne
peux pas annoncer avec le ministre
caraco voici ce qu'on a décidé parce que
si je viens on fait le déplacement et
qu'on dit aux indépendantistes venez
autour de la table parce que c'est là où
vous déciderez si on annonce avant c'est
légitimement ils diront pourquoi c'est
janvier et donc là ils ont accepté de
nous recevoir si j'ose dire de faire la
suite de la réunion qui a tenu la
première ministre en Nouvelle-Calédonie
nous sommes toujours dans la même
philosophie monsieur Sueur débilatéral
puis des trilatérales puis une avancée
vers le consensus ça s'inscrira dans
l'avenir dans la République mais
cependant je ne veux pas comme dirait le
général de Gaulle me lier les mains ou
nous lier les mains avant d'y aller
est-ce que serait évidemment
incompréhensible cependant il faudra
bien que ces provincial se tiennent bon
donc il faudra aussi parce que nous
avons un Conseil d'État nous avons des
règles européennes nous avons en Conseil
constitutionnel il faudra bien que nous
mettions d'accord sur ce corps électoral
et ces élections locales qui sont
importantes puisque les provinces vous
le savez bien ont des compétences fortes
en Nouvelle-Calédonie donc
je veux redire qu'il s'agit pas de
nouvelles référendum d'autodétermination
que nous ne sommes pas contre le
référendum de projet annoncé par le
ministre les autres plats précédents
mais que la date nous nous engageons pas
sur une date voilà il faut qu'elle se
tienne une fois qu'on aura fait ce
travail et la méthodologie évoquée par
le ministre délégué c'est des groupes de
travail sur tous les sujets
institutionnels mais pas que notamment
nickel qui va être bien complexe parce
que vous savez bien que ce sont des
sujets très capitalistiques et par
ailleurs très identitaires par ailleurs
et avec des des envies de puissance
étrangères auxquels nous devons faire
face voilà et quand nous serons prêts et
nous l'espérons le plus rapidement
possible mais il sera dit dans moins
d'un an quand même un calendrier qui est
effectivement serré et ben nous
reviendrons devant l'opinion publique et
c'est grand devant les Chambres et
devant le président de la République où
il est proposé le consensus que nous
espérons avoir trouvé dans les jours et
semaines qui viennent en engageant cette
discussion là bas
je vous en prie c'est l'affaire du
gouvernement
merci Monsieur le Ministre bientôt nous
allons donc continuer notre travail
cette fois-ci sur le projet de loi de
finance pour 2023 en abordant les
missions budgétaires et la première
d'entre elles et celle relative à la
sécurité
je suis pas le peut-être en même temps
d'immigration d'asile et l'intégration
et de l'ensemble et puis après je donne
la parole aux rapporteur respectifs
monsieur le roi notamment madame Jourda
et d'autres importants ne peuvent pas
être là mais certains interviendront
pour leur compte vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le ministre à bientôt
merci monsieur le Président peut-être
rapidement parce que je crois que ça
fait
des répétitions pour les sénateurs de la
commission des lois puisque nous avons
longuement parlé de ces sujets lors de
la loopy et vous verrez que le budget
2023 n'est qu'une déclinaison de la
première année de mise c'est un
cinquième discussion en commission par
deux fois et dans l'hémicycle pour faire
très vite vous constaterez sénateurs que
ce que vous avez voté en loopy est
parfaitement respecté dans les
propositions du PLF que ce soit sur la
sécurité que ce soit sur l'immigration
que ce soit sur la sécurité civile à
l'exception des annonces qu'a fait le
président de la République puisqu'il a
rajouté quelques centaines de millions
d'euros lors de la réunion avec les
acteurs de la sécurité civile et donc
nous les rajouterons bien évidemment
en amendement au PLF et au amendement à
la Love Me pour ce qui concerne
l'Assemblée nationale vous en aurez à
discuter sans doute en CMP si je reviens
sur la sécurité je veux souligner que
l'un des grands efforts de la Lemmi et
donc de l'année 23 c'est l'augmentation
très effectifs
2018 3018 effectif créé dans la police
la gendarmerie soit un tiers de la note
micrée dès l'année prochaine et le tiers
d'après sera l'année d'après en 2024
donc les les deux tiers de la loopi en
effectifs seront créés Jeux olympiques
écoudiants de rugby oblige ce sera donc
7400 nouveaux policiers en tout mais
évidemment un rendez-vous très important
monsieur le Président de recrutement de
formation pour ces nouveaux effectifs je
veux d'ailleurs dire que dès l'année
prochaine je suis en capacité de créer
plus de 60 brigades de gendarmerie dans
les départements donc c'était pas une
promesse en l'air puisque dès l'été
prochain j'aurai l'occasion de détailler
si vous le souhaitez la façon dont nous
y prenons mais j'étais la longuement
expliqué également lors de la lothmie
nous pouvons créer ces nouvelles
brigades de gendarmerie en prenant des
gendarmes sorties d'école et non pas des
gendarmes qui sont dans d'autres
brigades voilà donc je pense que ça
chacun aura pu le constater je veux
souligner aussi
la création de pour la première fois
depuis 17 ans la recréation des agents
de préfecture je crois que après deux
ans de stagnation des effectifs depuis
que je suis mise intérieur je remercie
le président de la réplique et
l'après-midi d'avoir recréé quasiment
400 postes on en a parlé dans l'autre
mise à jour préfecture qui connaissait
une baisse continuelle c'est une
cinquantaine de postes pour l'année
prochaine vous avez vu la recréation des
six préfectures lors du déplacement du
président de la République en Mayenne
j'ai aussi souligné parce que les élus
que vous êtes sont intéressés par les
questions des élus locaux une
augmentation très importante du effet
épidère et notamment de la
vidéoprotection puisque nous augmentons
sans cesse les crédits en charge pour
aider les communes à celle des caméras
vidéoprotection ce sera 168 millions
d'euros sur toute la période et donc 22
millions d'euros pour l'année 2023 sur
les équipements on continue notre
travail 4800 véhicules
achetés par la police et la gendarmerie
je rappelle que nous avons changé déjà
deux tiers du parc automobile dans le
quinquennat précédent on continue à
rénover les les les
commissariats les brigades de
gendarmerie 340 millions consacrés à la
rénovation en plus de crédits habituels
au brigade de gendarmerie au
commissariat de police on a déjà rénové
plus de 700 le réseau radio du futur qui
est lancé à partir de l'année prochaine
avec les crédits qui commencent à être
débloqués et les 36 nouveaux
hélicoptères de la sécurité civile qui
commence également à être acheté je veux
aussi dire que nous aurons l'occasion
pour le sujet immigration qui va aussi
être à l'Outre-mer de revoir le les
opérations chicandra de Mayotte sans
doute aussi une discussion autour de
harpie en Guyane vous avez vu les
annonces que nous avons pu faire avec le
ministre de la Justice les comptes
publics pour la sécurisation totale de
l'aéroport de Cayenne pour lutter contre
les contre les mules je veux aussi
souligner le travail très important que
nous mettrons en place en terme d'im
irrégulière j'ai eu l'occasion de dire
tout à l'heure qu'on avait augmenté de
20% les reconduites à la frontière alors
que nous sommes encore mois de novembre
par rapport à 2021 et ce matin j'ai
accepté un amendement de Monsieur Ciotti
ils ont à doubler le nombre de places
encras dans le quinquennat qui viennent
et donc nous ferons à peu près 500
places de crasse supplémentaires dès
l'année prochaine ce qui sera évidemment
très très important les crédits que vous
constaterez pour la lutte ou très bien
irrégulière augmente de façon très
importante puisque c'est 34% par exemple
pour simplement les centres de rétention
ou les l.ra je veux aussi enfin terminer
mon propos en disant que nous continuons
le travail à la fois sur l'intégration
plus de 51 millions d'euros sur les
volets intégration notamment de langue
française qui souhaitant le projet de
loi immigration que nous avons commencé
à déplorer mais c'est également vrai des
moyens de donner à l'OFPRA puisque nous
devons continuer notre délai traitement
le plus rapide possible là aussi j'ai
accepté un abonnement du groupe ce matin
pour nous donner comme objectif de 60
jours d'études pour un dossier de
l'OFPRA nous parviendrons avec les
moyens supplémentaires je rappelle que
ces 200 équivalents temps plein
supplémentaires pour pour l'OFPRA et
je crois que nous pouvons considérer que
le travail que nous mettons autour de la
DASS se vérifie puisqu'on a pour la
première fois monsieur le Président
c'était une question qu'on m'avait posée
l'année dernière sous exécuter la dame
non pas parce qu'il y avait moins
d'immigrés nous le savons que ce n'était
pas le cas et parce que nous avons
traité plus rapidement les dossiers et
ainsi évitant cette aide de verser à la
demande du Conseil d'État à ceux qui
demandent l'asile ce qui prouve notre
efficacité on sait tous qu'il faut
améliorer en revanche le côté
juridictionnel c'est-à-dire l'accès vers
la CNDA c'est l'objet d'ailleurs
d'un d'une des dispositions du texte et
reprenant d'ailleurs vos propositions de
votre rapport tout ça pour dire que je
suis un ministre de l'Intérieur heureux
qui va augmenter ses crédits d'un
milliard 400 millions d'euros à peu près
je voudrais anticiper une question
seulement 200 millions d'euros sont
prévus pour l'inflation je rappelle que
le ministère de d'ailleurs c'est un
ministère essentiellement de personnel
et donc il y a un mystère et
certainement personnel évidemment
l'inflation a moins d'intérêt que
lorsque c'est un ministère qui utilise
beaucoup de matériel pour l'inflation
s'applique et donc malgré l'inflation je
crois que cette hausse sans précédent
qui correspond à lobby que vous avez
voté nous permettra d'être au
rendez-vous des politiques publiques que
vous exigez
merci de la parole peut-être monsieur le
roi a rapporteur la mission sécurité
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre effectivement vous avez raison
on a largement discuté dans la loopnie
les chiffres de la mission sécurité pour
2023 sont en hausse c'est incontestable
et personne ne les conteste conformément
à la trajectoire de la locmi pour 2023
et 2024 si nous n'avons aucune
inquiétude quand je dis le nom il est
vraiment collectif avec l'ensemble des
forces de sécurité nous pouvons en avoir
légitimement davantage pour la suite
notre crainte ma crainte aussi et
d'accentué par le fait que la
répartition des crédits par mission et
programme n'est pas défini dans la lovni
qui ne convoque qui ne prévoit qu'une
trajectoire applicable à l'ensemble du
ministère de l'Intérieur ma question est
simple comment garantir la réalisation
de cette trajectoire qui est on ne peut
plus positive je rappelle que le Sénat
première lecture la beauté
300 cette voix sur 334 comment on
garantir la réalition de cette
trajectoire prévue pendant une notamment
dans les dernières années du quinquennat
car jusqu'en 2024 nous sommes convaincus
tous et vous le savez puisque dans les
différentes auditions ils se sont
ouverts à vous il y a aucune inquiétude
par contre passé la Coupe du Monde et
les Jeux Olympiques il y a des questions
qu'on se pose
merci Monsieur le roi
titre de la mission asile immigration
intégration merci monsieur le Président
si vous le permettez je vais être un
petit peu plus bavarde que Monsieur
Leroy si vous motorisez à trois
questions d'un coup en rafale
et après je laisserai ma place ma
première question est relative à la
location pour les demandeurs d'asile
alors j'ai entendu monsieur le ministre
que vous indiquez que elle était dans
sous-exécution cette allocation cette
année du fait de l'amélioration des
traitements ceci étant l'amélioration du
délai des traitements
plafonne et cette allocation elle est
aussi octroyée au réfugiés ukrainien
dont le nombre sur le territoire
français est assez important et il est
attendu pour être plus important encore
or dans le budget la dotation est en
baisse de 36%, est-ce pertinent au
regard de ces deux éléments de l'avoir à
ce point diminué c'est ma première
question
la seconde est relative aux occupés
alors et à l'exécution des hôpitaux le
président de la République avait indiqué
qu'un taux d'exécution enfin le taux
d'exécution serait de 100% puis il a
ensuite précisé que il serait de 100%
pour les occultes prononcés pour des
raisons d'ordre public alors où en
sommes-nous sur l'exécution de ces au
qtf précises et cela signifie t-il qu'on
abandonne l'exécution des autres
et enfin troisième question qui est plus
d'actualité mais qui peut avoir l'impact
sur le budget 2023 monsieur le ministre
devait annoncer ce matin avec Monsieur
le Ministre Olivier du socle
des mesures qui pourraient être prises
dans le projet de loi sur l'immigration
que vous envisagez et dont une qui était
la régularisation des personnes en
situation régulière qui travailleraient
dans des filières professionnelles en
tension
cela ressemble à six méprendre à un
nouveau critère d'élargissement de la
circulaire Valls qui permet
de régulariser des personnes qui sont
des clandestins qui sont entrés en
situation irrégulière sur le territoire
comment faire pour que cela ne soit pas
pour parler de trivialement un appel
d'air et une incitation à l'immigration
irrégulière
merci Jordan madame belureau pour le
compte de pour le compte de madame
kukkermann qui s'excuse et qui est
rapporteur des crédits de la mission
administration générale et territoriale
de l'État et tout particulièrement sur
les sous-préfectures en fait puisque
après l'émission prioritaire des
préfectures 2022 et 2025 et puis le
projet de loi d'orientation et le
programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur qui prévoit un renforcement
des services déconcentrés a été donc
récemment annoncé un véritable
réarmement de l'État territorial alors
évidemment on est tous là on se réjouit
de cette prise de conscience de pour nos
territoires pour permettre un relais
auprès de nos élus locaux qui ont bien
besoin et puis nous savons que depuis 10
ans ça fait suite à des coupes
budgétaires puisqu'il y a eu une
suppression cumulée de 14% de l'effectif
initial de l'administration territoriale
entre 2010 et 2020 et puis il y a aussi
des réformes de nombreuses réformes je
vous suis rappelé en effet qu'il y a eu
depuis le 1er janvier 2021 les
secrétariats généraux comme un
départementaux que c'est assez récent et
que nous n'avons pas encore un bilan et
que donc aujourd'hui nous avons un
nouveau plan d'action pour les
préfectures à horizon 2025 donc il
serait important que nous ayons quelques
précisions plus de techniques donc les
questions que Madame cukkerman souhaite
vous poser mais que nous souhaitons
aussi tous vous poser c'est que est-ce
que la création des 210 équivalents
temps plein sur les trois prochaines
années 1 est-ce que ça vous paraît
suffisant pour réarmer l'état
territorial comment ces ETP vont être
répartis demain le déjumelage des cinq
sous-préfectures et la création d'une
nouvelle sous-préfecture en Guyane vous
paraissent-ils répondre de manière
satisfaireante aux besoins de plus
d'états dans les territoires ruraux sur
quels critères entendez-vous basé vous
baser pour rééquilibrer la répartition
des emplois entre les préfectures et
qu'elles sont évidemment les préfectures
qui seront concernées par ces mouvements
ça nous intéresse tous quelle mesure
concrètes seront mises en œuvre pour
renforcer l'attractivité des métiers de
l'Administration territoriale ça c'est
un sujet notamment dans les
sous-préfectures rurales qui peinent
évidemment comme vous le savez tous à
recruter en tout cas nous nous
souhaitons en effet que nous sous
préfectures ça c'est Nadine bellura que
nous sous préfectures de nouveau
reprennent J et nous avons bien besoin
de la présence de l'État dans nos
territoires ruraux et non heureux mais
évidemment dans un département comme le
mien Linde évidemment il va sans dire
que nous avions trois sous-préfecture
maintenant nous n'avons que deux donc je
ne sais pas peut-être que
c'est envolée de préfecture nous sera
bienveillante merci
le roi a demandé la parole non juste une
précision monsieur le ministre vous avez
dit dans la réalisation des 200
nouvelles brigades de gendarmerie qui en
aurait 60 en 2023 heure j'ai consulté
mes fiches il semblerait que
le chiffre que nous avons est de 30 pour
2023 alors vous annoncez une
merveilleuse nouvelle puisque vous le
multipliez par deux merci je voudrais
juste monsieur le ministre me faire le
relais de Madame Françoise Dumont qui
rapporte pour avis des crédits relatifs
à la sécurité civile qui est également
pour les pâtes là aujourd'hui de deux
observations aux deux questions de sa
part ensuite des interrogations des
parents ensuite des propos tenus par
président de la République récemment sur
la sécurité civile s'interroge sur les
articulations des différentes annonces
en particulier sur la notion de
réarmement aérien d'urgence à hauteur de
250 millions d'euros un chiffre qui ne
recouvre pas selon que ne recouvre pas
ceux du programme 161 relatif à la
sécurité civile et qui semble selon
madame Dumont en deçà des ambitions de
la locmi elles se traite donc avoir des
précisions sur le périmètre des
objectifs ainsi que les liens avec le
projet de loi de finance 2023 de ce plan
de réarmement aérien d'urgence et enfin
sur le renforcement de la flotte des
Canadairs où elle estime que d'ici la
fin du quinquennat devrait avoir un
renouvellement important elle indique le
projet loi de finance pour 2023 ne
contient aucun crédit dédié au
renouvellement de nos Canadair comment
comptez-vous tenir ce calendrier
ambitieux d'Ital voilà Monsieur Louise
peut-être monsieur Durand et puis après
le ministreur à la parole et Madame
Gatel aussi une toute petite bien
monsieur Durin merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre après les
avis documentés des rapporteurs trois
courtes questions le Sénat dans sa
grande sagesse qui a choisi de d'adopter
le premier avait déposé plusieurs
amendements sur l'aide de collectivités
locales pour la création de Sam brigade
de gendarmerie sur un fond de 200
millions d'euros par an pour
l'immobilier de la gendarmerie c'est des
crédits qui n'apparaissent pas tous au
programme 512 encore c'est dans une
normal vu le le timing est-ce que le
texte budgétaire sera en mai amender ce
que nous
[Musique]
et du temps perdu sur la régularisation
toutes ces personnes donc comment
comment cela va-t-il se traduire très
concrètement
si Monsieur Durin madame la Présidente
française Gatel
merci merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre moi je m'appelle
parler d'argent donc voilà je vais
détendre l'atmosphère je parle un pas de
plus d'État mais de mieux d'État parce
que je pense qu'au-delà des moyens dont
moi je me réjouis pour réarmer la
présence de l'État territorial je pense
qu'on a aussi un vrai sujet autour de
l'optimisation de l'organisation des
services de l'État dans les territoires
notamment avec des agences qui parfois
ont une très belle autonomie que le
préfet a réussi à encadrer au moment de
la crise sanitaire mais que ce serait
bien que par un temps ordinaire on
arrive aussi à mieux gérer les choses
alors de nos collègues Agnès canaillé
Eric et rouge ont élaboré un rapport
qu'on aura sans doute le plaisir de vous
remettre que sans insolence ils ont
appelé à la recherche de l'État dans les
territoires et nous avons effectivement
constaté que parfois l'État était d'une
très grande discrétion et qu'il faut
vous avez raison réarmer les
sous-préfectures parce que c'est là que
l'État a besoin d'être présent pour
accompagner les élus et pas simplement
faire un contrôle de l'égalité alors moi
j'ai une question monsieur le ministre
qui est encore une fois ne coûte rien ou
presque on a un vrai sujet dans les
départements où le préfet est également
préfet de région et où le secrétaire
général cumule cette fonction avec celle
de Sous Préfet d'un arrondissement ça
veut dire qu'à un moment la personne
étant excellente elle est totalement
épuisée ou absolument invisible donc
allez-vous améliorer l'organisation en
permettant qu'un préfet de région ne
soit pas en même temps préfère de
départements et enfin
une autre question différente sur les
titres de séjour monsieur le ministre on
a aujourd'hui on l'a évoqué des
entreprises qui sont très grandes
difficultés parce que elle ne trouve pas
dans certains métiers des citoyens enfin
de nos concitoyens qui veulent occuper
donc ces entreprises et j'en ai plein
dans mon département
veulent faire venir des travailleurs qui
viennent d'autres pays et ça n'est pas
la croix et la bannière pour les faire
venir c'est pire que ça c'est à dire on
a des délais qui sont absolument
décourageants voire des non-réponses de
demandes de titres de séjour donc est-ce
que les choses peuvent s'améliorer
est-ce que ça peut s'accélérer tout en
naturellement respectant les les droits
ou la loi dans ces dispositifs mais ça
devient vraiment très critique monsieur
le ministre merci merci
je vais dire la parole au ministre et
bien j'ai eu de la parole merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président d'abord peut-être
pour Monsieur Leroy je veux bien
si le président de la commission le veut
vous transmettre pour toute la
commission la ventilation par crédit sur
les 5 ans donc je l'ai promise dans le
débat que nous avons eu je la donne à
l'Assemblée nationale dans les heures
qui viennent et je vous la donne bien à
vous vous allez à la fois la répartition
des effectifs et les répartitions de
crédit sur les 5 ans évidemment rien
n'est marqué dans le marbre parce que
dans 5 ans il va se passer plein de
choses mais vous verrez comment on
décompose des 15 milliards pour tout
l'ensemble de la commission si vous le
souhaitez bien évidemment
la question de la gendarmerie j'ai dit
je pourrais faire 60 brigades mais je
sais très bien que je ne ferai pas parce
qu'il faut quand même les loger donc
j'avoue que c'est une tribune facile
puisque ça dépend quel type de brigade
on veut quand je suis allé en Guyane et
j'ai fait la concentration avec les élus
ils m'ont dit on veut des brigades
fluviales sur le ya pop et le Maroni ça
m'étonne pas le même nombre de gendarmes
ça demande pas le nom de matériel et
c'est pas le même lieu il y a des gens
qui me disent moi je veux un PGHM je
veux pas une brigade territoriale j'ai
des retours pour me dire je veux une
brigade fluviale parce que j'ai des
problèmes y compris en métropole de
police de l'eau je veux des
brigadésquestres voilà donc c'est pas
moi j'ai dit on fait deux embrigades en
dur si vous le souhaitez mais si les
élus veulent
s'adapter on s'adapte donc on peut faire
entre 20 et 70 ce brigade de l'année
prochaine mais ça dépend où on les met
bien sûr en tout cas vous remarquerez
dans les effectifs que je vous ai donné
que le nombre de gendarmes dans les
quatre premières années de brigade
territoriales je sors les ufm EGM ce
je l'avais dans la main et je n'ai plus
dans la main
sont à
380 chaque année
donc on a le quoi puis si on fait à peu
près 312 et 378 sortie de d'école sans
compter seuls qui sont aujourd'hui en ce
moment dans les écoles donc on est on a
de quoi faire faire ces brigades ça
dépendra du lieu qui les accueille si on
a un lieu qui est une ancienne brigade
de gendarmerie qu'il faudrait rénover
trois coups de peinture et ça va bah ça
va très vite si on a lieu qu'il faut
construire c'est bien ce Center que ça
met du temps sur l'utilise avec la
police municipale dans un hôtel de
police peut-être pourquoi pas donc le
sujet sera pas tellement le nombre de
gendarmes que l'endroit pour les
accueillir puisque vous savez que les
militaires dorment en famille et qu'il
faut évidemment bien les accueillir je
sais que vous le savez quasiment le que
personne ici sur la question de la dame
moi je veux répondre à Madame la
scénariste pour dire que c'est hors
ukrainien puisque les Ukrainiens certes
touchent la protection temporaire la
dame mais ils sont aussi plus nombreux
que les demandeurs d'asile classique à
travailler puisqu'ils peuvent travailler
dès le premier jour de l'arrivée sur le
territoire national donc ce que nous
faisons c'est que nous inscrivons le
budget de Lada hors U bien nous ne
connaissons pas le nombre d'ukrainien
qui vous restait sur le territoire
national on constate d'ailleurs qu'il y
a de nouveau des moins de flux qui
rentrent que de gens qui s'en vont
notamment tous ceux qui habitaient dans
la région qui n'étaient pas concernée
par les territoires qui sont
actuellement les plus en guerre pardon
de l'exprimer ainsi qui était la
frontière orientale de l'Ukraine puisque
dans un premier temps on a eu beaucoup
de départ de l'ensemble des Ukrainiens y
compris des gens de Kiev et que nous
avons beaucoup d'Ukrainiens qui
repartent sur soit directement l'Ukraine
soit dans les pays frontaliers et donc
je ne partage pas le constat que il y en
aura de plus en plus sauf évidemment
évolution de la guerre qui dépend bien
sûr pas de pas de nous ni de vous ni de
moi donc on a un accord si j'ose dire
avec le ministère des comptes publics
puisque cette année ça nous a coûté en
plus de la date 244 millions la version
de Lada pour les pour les pour les
ukrainiens et nous avons un accord qu'en
pdfr on pourra intégrer en gestion ces
crédits ce qu'on a pu faire cette année
sans reposer de problèmes il s'agit bien
donc de Lada hors protection temporaire
pour répondre à votre question et on
continuera à diminuer le nombre de jours
qu'on attend sur les délais puisque on
est désormais à 140 jours en 2022 on
arrivera à baisser encore ce stock on
est d'ailleurs le pays ce n'est pas
assez dit c'est sûr que c'est juste une
prouesse de la fonction publique et donc
par définition ça fait pas la une des
journaux mais nous sommes le pays qui
traitons le plus rapidement les demandes
d'asile de l'ensemble de l'Union
européenne grâce aux efforts très
importants que vous avez accepté de nos
consentir notamment les recrutements des
200 effectives supplémentaires à l'OFPRA
de nombreux contrats actuels alors sur
les qtf bon c'est très intéressant cette
question parce que ça me permet de dire
prendre un petit temps je sais pas je
pense que malheureusement je me
répéterai en prévision du débat
immigration mais je pense que ce débat
est
et très important à comprendre
démocratiquement j'essaie de le répéter
sans cesse
chacun commente un taux d'exécution de
qtf que personne ne connaît
je m'explique
les pourcentages exécution de qtf ne
reposent sur aucune réalité statistique
publiée par quelqu'un donc en fait ce
que fait la presse c'est qu'elle prend
et je veux bien avouer que les
politiques le commentent donc je me mets
bien volontiers dans l'erreur que nous
faisons collectivement elle prend le
nombre de qtf Me par les préfectures
dans une année pleine 1er janvier au 31
décembre je prends l'exemple de 2021
120000 et regarde le nombre d'exécutions
de ces eqtf il y a deux types
d'exécution vous le savez une des gens
qui font un occupé
des parts volontaires ce qu'avait
l'assassin présumé de la petite Lola
elle avait un mois pour partir du
territoire national ça c'est la moitié
des hôpitaux en France à peu près et
l'autre moitié des qtf dite forcés c'est
à dire des gens qui sont sous contrainte
normalement obligé de quitter le
territoire national la question c'est
est-ce qu'il y a assez de race que cette
crame et sous contrat 60 000 également
l'année 2021 et on regarde le nombre de
gens qu'on a reconduit à la frontière en
l'occurrence ces dernières autour de
16000 me semble-t-il et on dit c'est le
pourcentage qui fait exécuté c'est 120
/
16000 et donc on se retrouve avec un
taux de qtf qui grosso modo moins de 20
%. des gens qui vous disent si on
ressent les aider on met que des forcés
vous dise regardez c'est encore plus bas
mais il faut tout prendre sinon
alors d'abord ce chiffre la base n'est
pas la bonne parce que en 2021 les
préfectures mettent 120 000 qtf mais
ceux qu'on exécute en 2021 c'est pas les
exécutifs de 2021 c'est les ex qui ont
été pris avant c'est à dire comme on a
un an pour exécuter le qtf en exécuter F
un eqfmi en mars 2020 par la préfecture
du Nord on arrivera à l'exécuter très
certainement qu'en 2021 quand c'est
quelqu'un qui n'a pas laissé passer
consulaire est un départ forcé on va
mettre du temps et donc la base de
départ n'est pas la bonne et parfois la
base c'est 20000 à 30000 de différence
si je prends l'année 2020 de mémoire ça
va être 100 000 au qtf l'année 2021
120000 donc d'abord votre base de notre
base collective n'est pas la bonne je
t'expliquerai après comment on va
changer ça pour qu'on ait effectivement
des chiffres sur lesquels on peut
discuter que ce soit pas un débat 20
deuxièmement sur la moitié de ses auqtf
madame la sénatrice il y a des recours
[Musique]
comment dirais-je
forcé troisièmement c'est pour ça que
j'ai demandé qu'on inscrit désormais
tous les occultés dans le FPR c'est
qu'il y a des gens qui partent sans nous
le dire et il y en a beaucoup
non il y en a beaucoup non dans tous les
occupés
vous assurer que les auqtf ne sont pas
rentrés dans le FPR
ne sont entrés dans les FPR que les EQF
de personnes qui sont dangereuses pour
l'ordre public la maman la la l'assassin
de la petite Lolane n'était pas rentrée
au FPR elle est pourtant un qtf elle
n'avait ne présentait aucun trouble à
l'ordre public on aurait déjà discuté
mais la mère de tutelle de départ
volontaire et quand des gens se
présentent à la passe de Roissy ou
d'Orly ou d'ailleurs c'est pas un sujet
et dis-moi je veux retourner dans mon
pays parce qu'on m'a dit de partir de
mon pays et bien si elle n'est pas au
FPR la police aux frontière les laisse
passer puisqu'ils ont un passeport une
pièce d'identité de ce pays ils ne sont
pas irréguliers de leur pays sur le
nôtre et on ne signale pas à la
préfecture du Nord car Roissy une dame à
qui on a mis à qtf fait partie on ne le
met que lorsqu'il est accompagné par un
policier de la police aux frontières qui
a fait le voyage avec elle ou le fille
qui lui a payé un déplacement et qui dit
voilà elle est partie donc il y a des
milliers de personnes peut-être même
plus qui partent chaque année notre
territoire qui endoc ETF qu'il exécute
eux-mêmes mais qui ne nous le disent pas
en le mettant dans FPR toute personne
qui va passer nos frontières sonnera si
j'ose dire lorsqu'on fera le contrôle
des entités de sortie et permettra non
pas de les retenir mais de cocher le
fait qu'elle soit partie d'abord on aura
donc une base qui ne peut qu'augmenter
quatrièmement on a un sujet c'est à dire
que les gens peuvent partir mais pas
dans leur pays d'origine peuvent aller
en Belgique peuvent aller en Allemagne
voilà en Espagne il y a pas de contrôle
au frontières donc elle sans doute plein
de qtf qu'on compte comme étant pas
expulsé parce qu'ils ne sont pas
retournés dans leur pays d'origine mais
qui passe par puisqu'on a un accord de
libre-échange entre les personnes dans
un pays qui ne connaît pas de contrôle
aux frontières donc il y aura sans doute
une part de personnes qu'on ne connaîtra
jamais comme étant expulsé du territoire
national sauf si c'est une des questions
que je répondrai à propos des
préfectures on dit aux agents de
préfecture c'est un des grands choix du
projet de loi qu'on va vous présenter
avec Olivier du soft sauf si on dit aux
agents de préfecture arrêtez de demander
des papiers à des gens qui ne posent
aucun problème sur le territoire de la
République mais concentrez-vous sur les
personnes qui ont un arrêté de plus de
reconduite et par exemple qu'au bout de
quatre mois et un jour on aille voir la
personne qui aurait dû partir pour dire
mais pourquoi vous êtes pas parti où on
l'appelle on la convoque de nouveau ce
qu'on ne fait pas aujourd'hui je veux
bien l'avouer volontiers par manque
d'effectif dans les préfectures par
manque d'organisation interne parce
qu'il y a trop de gens qui se présentent
dans les fils des étrangers dans les
préfectures etc etc donc oui on peut
exécuter 100% des auqtf madame
assénatrice
si nous nous comptons les choses qui
doivent être comptées si nous supprimons
les recours indus c'est l'objet du
projet de loi que nous proposons on
passerait de 12 catégories de recours à
4 ce qui est déjà beaucoup enfin ça me
ferait gagner entre guillemets trois
fois plus de temps on sait tous que les
personnes qu'on a du mal à reconduire
c'est les personnes qui sont déboutées
du droit d'asile et donc la grande
proposition qu'on fait dans le projet de
loi c'est de dire refus d'asile vaut qtf
et le tribunal administratif aura 15
jours ce sera écrit dans la loi pour
statuer sur le refus d'asile parce
qu'aujourd'hui vous arrivez vous
demandez l'asile on vous le donne pas
l'OFPRA ça fait six mois imaginons
contiennent ce délai vous faites un
appel à la CNDA c'est suspensif on est
reparti pour 8 9 mois ça dépend des cas
mais enfin à peu près ça fait un peu
plus d'un an et puis la semaine dernière
vous dit non c'est comme 70% des cas de
d'asile en France là le préfet prend une
QdF et là vous avez le droit de demander
un recours contre votre
UTF les parties pour 6 mois puis si on
vous dit non vous avez le droit d'aller
au Conseil d'État et en gros les gens
restent entre un an et demi et deux ans
sur le territoire national entre temps
ils ont peut-être fait des enfants et là
on vous dit ben le qtf était bon mais la
vérité c'est que ma vie familiale elle a
changé donc je j'ai un occupé parce que
je ne peux pas exécuter qu'on m'a
empêcher d'exécuter puisque vous avez
une multiplication de recours qui
m'empêche de l'exécuter donc si nous
adoptons le texte immigration évidemment
après un débat que nous aurons ensemble
mais je crois que j'invente rien n'aura
pas buffet il avait déjà en partie
soulignée nous pourrons atteindre les
100% de qtf les quelques points qui nous
manquera pour faire les 100% de qtf
c'est soit des laisser passer
consulaires pour les personnes plus
dangereuse qui n'aurait pas été donné
par les pays enfin ça sera pas des
milliers de personnes non plus faut pas
non plus surestimer le laisser passer
consulaire ou les personnes qui sont non
éloignables j'ai pris l'exemple d'un
interview du monde des Syriens ou des
Afghans je ne sais pas si quelqu'un est
si propose que nous rétablissions nos
relations diplomatiques avec les
talibans c'est peut-être pas une bonne
chose mais en attendant on ne peut pas
exclure expulser des Afghans qui sont
sur le territoire national c'est un fait
donc la question de savoir qu'est-ce
qu'on fait de ces personnes à qui on
donne pas la vie mais qu'on ne peut pas
expulser les Allemands appellent ça le
la tolérance donc ils disent voilà vous
avez un papier le temps que votre régime
politique ne soit pas acceptable et le
jour où il redevient acceptable c'est
une forme de protection temporaire vous
parlez des Ukrainiens tout à l'heure on
vous ça ne crée pas de droit ici mais
vous repartirez dès que on pourra vous
expulser bref on aura cette occasion de
parler de tous ces sujets pour répondre
à votre question on est à 20% de plus
rien que cette année d'expulsion donc on
est autour de 18000 pour ceux donc on
peut compter parce que vous ai donc
assis démontré contre comptait pas tous
ceux qui partaient et on aura l'occasion
d'en reparler j'ai demandé au directeur
général des étrangers en France et je
viens j'écrirai votre président de
commission d'expliquer comment est-ce
que le service statistique de l'Insee on
peut faire une prise de température si
j'ose dire incontestable et incontesté
sinon ça fait ça crée évidemment tous
les tous les fantasmes du monde sur la
question mais je répondrai en même temps
à Monsieur Durin que votre question sur
le le titre de séjour métier en tension
bon
je lis quelques-unes exactitude depuis
ce matin j'en suis d'ailleurs fort
étonné
le titre de séjour métier en tension et
le contraire de la régularisation
massive de la régularisation Chevènement
au Valls
d'abord c'est ce que nous faisons
aujourd'hui depuis 10 ans c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui nous régularisons à peu
près 30 000 personnes selon la
circulaire valse 23000 vie privée
familiale 7000 au nom d'un travail au
noir qui est finalement régularisé mais
ce que nous faisons c'est que nous
régularisons les personnes ad vitam
c'est à dire que vous demandez votre
dossier de régularisation vous êtes
régularisé point le titre de séjour
métier en tension c'est pour un an c'est
pas de vitam et c'est parce que vous
êtes dans un métier attention et tant
que vous avez votre métier en tension ça
n'a rien à voir avec la régularisation
massive j'ai entendu le président du
groupe LR au Sénat je l'occasion de lui
demander rendez-vous en tout cas je l'ai
invité si tu souhaitais puisqu'on va
faire des grandes consultations
politiques expliciter ce que nous
proposons c'est qu'une proposition c'est
le contraire de la régularisation
massive je crois que le ministre du
socle d'ailleurs la partie expliqué tout
à l'heure dans l'hémicycle deuxièmement
on peut pas faire comme si il n'y avait
pas des métiers en tension dans lequel
le patronat lui-même demande qu'il est
plus immigration de travail et je crois
que l'enjeu de notre pays c'est comment
on diminue en proportion les migrations
familiales pour aller vers davantage
immigration de travail l'Allemagne a
grosso modo 10 points de plus
l'immigration de travail que nous
comment on en est arrivé là on est
arrivé là parce que nos titres de séjour
sont fondés sur plutôt la famille et pas
assez sur le travail bon donc nous ce
qu'on dit c'est bah voilà arrêtons de
mettre des choses sans cesse automatique
sur la famille et tout en respectant les
conventions européennes des droits de
l'homme tout en respectant le
regroupement familial bien évidemment on
propose de mettre une forme d'examen
quel examen de il faut quelqu'un parle
français pour être sur notre sol vous
avez vu ce que j'ai évoqué qui permet de
contrecarrer en partie l'automaticité
d'une immigration non contre les
familiale et d'autre part de créer un
titre spécifique pour le travail d'or
parce qu'il y a des gens en France qui
sont des invisibles qui mangent qui
travaillent dans les restaurants où nous
mangeons de temps en temps mais on
aimerait pas dans la cuisine pour savoir
ce qui s'est passé exactement vous savez
une partie des sans-papiers
malheureusement qui travaille dans le
métier de l'hôtellerie de la
restauration qui nettoie nos bureaux qui
délivre des repas on peut pas faire
comme si ces gens n'existaient pas et
qui ont qui payent de la fiscalité qui
paye des cotisations sans jamais avoir
la protection sociale donc nous disons
Luton fortement contre les entrepreneurs
les entreprises qui vont qui font du
travail au noir d'ailleurs le ministre
du Travail a proposé une mesure
extrêmement forte que la fermeture
administrative de l'entreprise
c'est-à-dire pas une amende mais on
arrête l'activité de la boîte c'est
quand même extrêmement fort et c'est
administratif c'est même pas judiciaire
en contrepartie nous disons bien
évidemment que nous devons discuter des
métiers en tension avec le patronat qui
dit bah moi cette année parce que chaque
année qu'on peut en parler et d'ailleurs
je le dis à chacune et à chacun des
sénateurs s'il y a bien un endroit où on
pourrait mettre un nombre
par quelques-uns parfois appellent ça
des quotas un nombre de titres de séjour
qu'on doit faire celui-là il est
pilotable il est pilotable en discutant
avec le monde économique on a besoin de
5000 serveurs ou de 5000 ou de 3000
médecins parce que je signale que les
titres mettent en tension ça peut être
aussi pour des des questions médicales
dans les dans les EHPAD enfin on a ce
débat oui ça dit ça existe parce que ce
métier est dans la liste des métiers
mais aujourd'hui la restauration ne
l'est pas donc chaque année l'idée c'est
qu'on remette dans un débat au Parlement
la liste des métiers en tension on peut
en ouvrir on peut enfermer ça dépend de
l'activité économique ça donne un an de
droit à la personne qui travaille et
puis c'est le contraire de la
régularisation puisque lorsqu'on
décidera que le métier n'est plus en
tension bah ces personnes ne pourra pas
rester sur le territoire national 900
des droits qu'il aurait créé dans la vie
privée et familiale donc vraiment je
voulais dire que c'est le contraire
vraiment le contraire de la
régularisation massive qui avait été qui
a été évoqué et on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler bien évidemment du coup ça me
permet de répondre à la question sur la
préfecture on a une CIN d'agents en plus
prévu pour l'année prochaine et 400 à
peu près je lui dis en préfecture pour
les 5 années qui viennent
malheureusement madame la sénatrice je
déplore mais comme d'autres avant moi
sans doute et comme vous vous cou ici
que dans les préfectures grosso modo ne
vont plus que deux types de personnes
les personnes qui demandent des papiers
ou les gens qui ont raté un permis de
conduire et qui doivent leur repasser il
n'y a pas beaucoup d'autres raisons
d'aller dans une préfecture une
sous-préfecture je ne dis pas que les
agents de préfecture ne font pas du
Conseil d'accompagne pas les
collectivités locales ne font pas du
contrôle de l'égalité n'accompagne pas
les les l'urbanisme mais les gens qui
vont physiquement dans une préfecture
désormais c'est extrêmement limité
puisque nous avons par ailleurs donné
beaucoup de délégations aux
collectivités locales ne serait-ce que
les pièces d'identité dont auparavant
vous le savez tous elles étaient la
panache de l'État maintenant elles sont
déconcentrées pas de décentralisée même
si ça tombe d'éduc considère que les
moyens ne sont pas toujours au
rendez-vous de déconcentration donc
l'une des grandes actions désormais des
agents de préfecture c'est le service
des étrangers quel est notre problème
alors on peut rajouter 3000 4000 5000
effectifs mais je pense que c'est pas la
même façon de travailler notre problème
c'est de dire aux agents de préfecture
arrêtons de contrôler les centaines de
milliers d'étrangers qui ne posent aucun
problème à la République à qui on donne
beaucoup de gestations en disant revenez
dans alors que vous avez un titre de
séjour de 10 ans moi je pense au vieux
Shibani de Tourcoing les gens qui ont 75
ans des Algériens qui ont parfois servi
dans l'armée française qu'on peut
choisir d'être français c'est leur droit
le plus stricte et à qui on dit faudra
venir demander votre titre de séjour à
la préfecture c'est extrêmement vexant
tout le monde prend du temps tout le
monde vérifie des dossiers dont on dit
tous à la fin que c'est un bon dossier
et pendant ce temps-là on n'est pas
assez bon sur l'accueil des primoirs
arrivants qui arrive sur le sol national
pour vérifier qu'il parle bien français
qui n'ont pas de casier judiciaire qui
ne sont pas suivis pour radicalisation
bref qu'ils sont bienvenue sur le
territoire de la République ou
poursuivre les auqtf justement puisque
je je crois démontrer qu'on était mal
organisés pour les suivre au point que
je ne suis pas capable de vous dire
aujourd'hui combien de personnes ont été
le territoire national ce qui n'est pas
vous en conviendrez normal dans un monde
parfait donc j'ai proposé que les
centaines de milliers de dossiers qui
sont étudiants et préfecture chaque
année ne le soit plus de manière
au cas par cas mais qu'on puisse le
faire de manière automatique sauf
exception ce qui permet quand même à
l'état de reprendre la main si on a un
doute sur une personne si un casier
judiciaire qui s'est rempli si on a une
dénonciation sur un alias pour
évidemment pouvoir convoquer l'étranger
il faut toujours la possibilité de
pouvoir contrôler la personne mais pas
de le faire manière à chaque fois
systématique donc tous les équilates en
temps plein que nous allons récupérer
seront mis sur le sujet de contrôle de
l'étranger soit de lutte contre
délinquance soit irrégulier et donc je
crois que ça renforcera aussi beaucoup
les moyens que les préfets auront à leur
disposition les sous-préfet pour faire
autre chose que du contrôle les
étrangers alors moi je suis pas en
accord avec Madame Gatel mais pas moi ce
sera sans doute la première fois de
notre vie mais je vais essayer de lui
démontrer que si on dit au préfet de
région qui n'est pas le préfet de
département vous allez créer un monstre
qui ne verra les choses que
régionalement et pas au niveau
départemental ce qui rend concret le
préfet de département en tout cas je
l'espère pour lui c'est qu'il vit la
même chose que ses collègues ses
collègues départementaux et qu'il a pas
une vision qui est
concentré dans une déconcentration parce
que on peut toujours faire de la de la
centralisation ailleurs qu'à Paris il y
a des centralisation régionales moi je
le préfet de région il n'a pas
d'autorité particulière sur les préfets
départements vous le savez c'est un de
ces collègues simplement il y a quelques
dossiers supplémentaires notamment la
planification économique poursuit les
dossiers notamment en lien avec la
région dans laquelle il est et par
ailleurs souvent le préfet de région pas
toujours mais les préfets zonal aussi
donc il utilise un certain nombre de
moyens mais le préfet de la de la de la
ville préfecture régionale
je regrette d'ailleurs qu'ils aient été
concentrés par la concentration des
régions la vérité c'est que c'est
préfets ça marchait très bien lorsqu'ils
avaient quelques départements 5,6 alors
disposition mais depuis la fusion des
grandes régions évidemment ça vous donne
l'impression que vous voyez jamais votre
effet de région alors la Bretagne n'a
pas été touchée on se demande par la
grâce de qui sans doute par la grâce de
jean-y Le Drian à l'époque mais en
nouvelle-aquitaine en Occitanie on peut
se poser on peut se poser la question
mais moi je ne suis pas favorable madame
la sénatrice à ce que on distingue le
privé de région du préfet de département
parce que sinon je crois qu'on va
renforcer il va vouloir à l'état-major
il va vouloir un directeur de cabinet il
va vouloir des collaborateurs on va
renforcer un échelon régional alors que
tout ce qu'on demande tous c'est qu'on
renforce échelon départemental et il me
semble que dans la chambre dans la
chambre du Sénat je peux dire que je
suis départementaliste je crains
personne bien sûr donc il faut pas il
faut pas je crois les les distinguer
mais on aura l'occasion d'en reparler si
vous le souhaitez sur les questions qui
concernent monsieur Durand le rapport
viguru moi j'ai l'occasion de dire dans
le débat que c'était un excellent
rapport je suis favorable assez
conclusions et je suis favorable au
changement si j'ose dire ou complément
de ce que peut faire les GPN ou l'iggn
donc si vous déposez un amendement je
l'accepterai bien bien volontiers sinon
on peut y travailler évidemment ensemble
même dans le cadre de l'aloememi si le
groupe socialiste le déposait pour que
vous fassiez le votre en CMP j'y serai
favorable je rendrai d'ailleurs public
le rapport Windguru d'ailleurs je
constate contre le titre de l'article de
presque que vous évoquez et le contenu
il y a un monde et je m'en félicite
puisque j'ai eu l'occasion de dire que
je voudrais que monsieur vigou avait
fait un excellent travail et que la
police peut améliorer largement les
choses c'est certain d'ailleurs monsieur
Vigouroux lui-même mais de côté
d'accepte pas la proposition tout le
monde connaît son adresse d'esprit de
contrôle
de récipissé d'identité il propose
d'autres choses pourquoi pas les mettre
les mettre en place en tout cas c'est
aussi un il y a le racisme
discrimination de la police il veut dire
mais il y a aussi entre les agents de
police et ce que subit la police aussi
beaucoup d'agents de police ou de force
de l'or parce que le rapport ne touche
pas avec la police concernant aussi la
gendarmerie j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de
dire
ça le traître
sale arabe c'est aussi quelque chose
qu'on dit à un policier c'est pas que
quelque chose que dit un policier bien
évidemment voilà donc moi je suis tout à
fait favorable évidemment à ce que
l'inspection les instructions générales
face leur les propositions et notamment
celle-ci de Monsieur
enfin pour la sécurité civile je veux
rassurer la sénatrice absente puis il y
a d'abord que les dessous annoncés par
le président d'un pays qui sont en plus
de la Love Me et non pas en moins de la
loopnie donc c'est à dire que c'est on
rajoute on additionne on ne soustrait
pas donc le montant d'augmentation est
donc évidemment du net et deuxièmement
oui c'est vrai que il y a pas le budget
pour les Canadiens mais comme a dit le
président de la République à cette
réunion d'abord avant de pouvoir acheter
des canadaires faudrait d'abord en
produire il faut même produire l'usine
qui construit les avions parce qu'on a
plus d'usine qui construit des avions
qui font des Canadairs donc d'abord on
construit l'usine puis après on va
construire des Canadairs donc
malheureusement construire une usine de
Canadair Canadair ou d'une autre marque
Canada étant comme frigidaire c'est la
marque du réfrigérateur bon un autre
avion il y a d'autres il y a d'autres
grandes entreprises aéronautiques
parfois française d'ailleurs qui nous
proposeraient peut-être de ce type
d'avion ça va pas se dérouler
malheureusement dans les 5 ans de la
Love Me et deuxièmement 90% de ces
achats 90% du moteur c'est européen
c'est à dire que l'Europe nous donne de
l'argent 90% du montant pour que nous
achetions ce cet avion donc quand même
nous pourrions acheter à la fin de notre
quinquennat des avions type Canada nous
pourrions tout à fait le faire dans le
cadre budgétaire évoqué puisque par
ailleurs on ne paye pas 100% d'achat
puisque c'est des achats groupés au
niveau européen
merci Monsieur du salon j'ai encore
trois interventions madame Jourda
monsieur Bourgi madame l'herbier oui
merci Monsieur Président Monsieur Miss
je souhaitais réagir suite à vos
réponses notamment sur celle relative
aux occf nous avons tout de même des
éléments sur les auqtf enfin même si je
peux admettre qu'on peut discuter du
périmètre bien sûr des chiffres ou du
décalage de l'exécution entre les
hôpitaux F prononcés et leur exécution
qui peut avoir lieu l'année suivante
mais la direction générale des étrangers
en France donc vos services nous donnent
des chiffres extrêmement clairs qui nous
ont été donnés d'ailleurs mercredi
dernier lors de l'audition sur le nombre
d'occuts prononcés le nombre exécuté
même si on la regarde avec un décalage y
compris sur le nombre de retours
spontanés qui ne sont pas très
importants
pour que les problèmes je suis tout à
fait d'accord c'est ce avec ce chiffre
d'affaires que je travaille mais c'est
des chiffres que nous connaissons ce que
je vais vous dire c'est qu'il y a un
continent que nous ne connaissons pas et
je pense que je vais le régler puisque
je crois peut-être que je regrette de
pas avoir eu cette idée avant mais je
suis allé voir comment ça se passait
dans un aéroport quand un policier quand
un étranger se présente à une bête de
d'un aéroport et dis-moi je veux
repartir chez moi j'ai mon billet
d'avion mais j'ai pas de papier à jour
parce que on m'a dit de partir que fait
le policier il le retient pas parce que
je suis quand même dit peut-être non
mais oui on est surpris de rien vous
savez donc je vérifie je vérifie quand
même les choses je suis comme beaucoup
d'entre vous j'ai été maire moi je
reviens des choses très concrètes
comment ça fonctionne en vrai voilà pas
dans les notes et le policier ils disent
mais non mais si quelqu'un se présente
évidemment on le s'il est national de ce
pays sinon il serait bloqué dans la zone
d'attendre de ce pays donc c'est pas la
peine mais si ce pays évidemment il
reprend l'avion et je leur ai demandé
mais du coup cette personne qui a un
occupé qui vous le dit vous avez tout
pas pris l'avion une fois passante dans
les positions frontières on voit bien
que ça va très vite que c'est rapide et
qu'on peut pas passer trop de temps et
bien je dis mais donc qu'est-ce que vous
faites de cette information que moi
monsieur Darmanin je rentre et on en
fait rien
dans cet air que si alors que quand la
personne a est inscrit au FPA soit pour
le retenir parce que il est retenu au
sens où la justice devrait l'avoir sous
la main ou parce que il est reparti chez
lui directement alors qu'il est
recherché parce qu'il est dangereux la
personne note et donc je veux vous dire
mais c'est pas une excuse en tant que
telle c'est que moi-même je je j'ai en
partie découvert que ne remontions pas
toutes les informations à la DGF puisque
il y a trois acteurs préfecture qui met
le qtf police aux frontières qui
contrôle les personnes les directions
général des étrangers en France qui fait
des statistiques donc il faut que tous
ces gens se parlent je sais qu'ils se
parlent mais je vois bien qu'on peut
quand même améliorer l'information on ne
connaît pas le taux d'exécution total et
complet de qtf on sera pas à 100% en les
comptant tous je dis bien volontiers
mais le chiffre que nous vous donnons
c'est le chiffre minimum pardon de dire
comme ça des EQF que nous comptons nous
parce que nous l'accompagnons par Luffy
ou par la police aux frontières
je n'ai pas fini monsieur le Président
si vous voulez bien sur le la
régularisation car ce que ça reste une
régularisation des clandestins sur les
filières en tension enfin j'entends bien
ce que ce que ce que vous souhaitez
faire je l'entends parfaitement mais je
crois qu'il existe déjà une procédure
qui permet à quelqu'un d'entrer sur le
territoire après une autorisation dans
la mesure où
l'employeur a démontré qu'il ne trouvait
pas ailleurs qu'il ne trouvait pas un
salarié donc c'est un une posture qui
existe mais qui est préalable à l'entrée
de l'étranger là tout de même nous
régularisons quelqu'un qui est entré
sans en avoir le droit donc j'ai un peu
de mal à concevoir que ça ne s'apparente
pas une régularisation alors qui sera
massive ou pas mais qui en tout cas va
se surajouter à ce qui existe ou alors
vous nous indiquez ça existait déjà et
je vois pas trop l'intérêt mais voilà je
pense que ce sont ce sont quand même
deux choses sensiblement différentes
bien monsieur saine Bourget merci
monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre je voudrais
apporter de l'eau à votre moulin
concernant les services des étrangers
dans les préfectures il se trouve que
depuis quelques années je relai
fréquente je les côtoie et je dois vous
dire avec beaucoup de gravité mais
manière très simple et très directe
c'est probablement l'un des services de
l'état où il y a le plus de souffrance
et le plus d'interrogations sur la quête
du sens d'une mission qui leur sont
confiées ce sont des services dans
lesquels il y a des hommes et des femmes
dévouées des hommes et des femmes qui
sont souvent sous-effectif et je le
conseille volontiers c'est pas
prioritaire sur le plan politique de
donner des moyens humains
supplémentaires assez services là et
pourtant et pourtant ils essaient de
faire au mieux les missions qui leur
sont confiées au fil des ans j'ai réussi
à créer une forme de complicité avec
certains d'entre eux qui m'ont expliqué
que pendant très longtemps c'était des
longues files d'attentes devant les
grilles de la préfecture qui était
alimentée par les étudiants qui
arrivaient en septembre-octobre et
auquel on demandait une carte étudiants
pour avoir un titre de séjour et
parallèlement les services scolarité des
universités demandées à ses étudiants
d'avoir un titre de séjour avant de les
inscrire c'était assez cascaïen
aujourd'hui et pas plus tard que la
semaine dernière j'ai eu l'occasion de
solliciter à deux reprises secrétaire
général de la préfecture sur des
situations particulières qu'on retrouve
partout en France première situation un
ressortissant étranger qui travaille
dans une entreprise de transport et de
transport scolaire en particulier
l'autocar ponce à Bédarieux le chef
d'entreprise me téléphone en me disant
écoutez monsieur le sénateur son titre
de séjour est arrivé à expiration depuis
deux mois il n'arrive pas à avoir de
rendez-vous à la préfecture et je reçois
des lettres comminatoires de la
direction de l'Emploi de la Formation
professionnelle pour me dire que cette
personne doit régulariser son dossier
actualiser son dossier ça n'était pas le
cas il a fallu que je décroche mon
téléphone que je contacte le secrétaire
général la préfecture et ce fut
solutionné en quelques jours deuxième
exemple et je peux le citer parce que
c'est
un étudiant étranger qui fait ses études
qui fait son stage au MEDEF dans
l'Hérault et le Medef souhaite le
recruter là aussi très grande difficulté
pour cette étudiant de passer du statut
d'étudiant au statut de salariés là
aussi avec la Jeune Chambre Économique
les dirigeants du Medef il a fallu qu'on
initie une démarche près de la
préfecture elle a abouti avec succès
mais pour des cas comme ceci qui
aboutissent avec succès parce que les
gens ont eu un interlocuteur un élu une
chambre consulaire un syndicat patronal
combien de personnes galèrent et se
retrouvent dans ces longues files qui
viennent finalement alimenter les
demandeurs qui s'adressent au service
des étrangers alors il y a quelques
années vos prédécesseurs de vos
prédécesseurs à trouver l'astuce plus de
files d'attente devant les préfectures
mais on prend rendez-vous sur internet
aujourd'hui il y a un vrai marché noir
des rendez-vous dans les préfectures qui
se développent vous avez des gens qui
sont à minuit une heure du matin
préemptés des rendez-vous et qui vont
ensuite les vendre sans 150 euros
parfois 500 euros pour des personnes qui
ont désespérées c'est cela la réalité
c'est la raison pour laquelle monsieur
le ministre sans préjugé du contenu de
votre projet de loi si jamais à cette
occasion là on pouvait simplifier
améliorer la doctrine et les process en
cours dans les préfectures pour que les
hommes et les femmes qui travaillent ne
jettent pas l'éponge tous les deux ou
trois ans pour changer de service pour
changer de direction parce que je peux
vous assurer qu'ils sont usés
usés par ces missions répétitives et
cette question permanente est lancinante
quel est le sens de ce que je fais c'est
chronophage ça coûte de l'argent à
l'état et parfois ils sont des abusés ça
c'était un témoignage que je voulais
apporter pour peut-être apporter aussi
un peu de l'eau à votre moulin dans le
cadre des travaux qui nous réuniront
deuxième question je vais insister
dessus sur les moyens de la sécurité
civile ça fait plusieurs fois que vous
nous indiquez vous comme le président de
la République qu'il y a une difficulté à
trouver un interlocuteur et une
entreprise pour pouvoir commander les
fameux
étudiants Canadair nous l'avons entendu
de votre bouche ici en commission des
lois de la bouche du président de la
République cette situation
la partageons tous c'est un constat que
nous partageons tous mais on ne peut pas
se satisfaire de faire un constat quel
alternative aujourd'hui nous pouvons
avec vous trouver pour
comment dire apporter quelques éléments
de réponse à ces soldats du feu qui ont
été particulièrement honorés sensibles à
l'accueil et au discours du président de
la République mais qui nous ont répondu
pour certaines questions des réponses
ont été apportées pour d'autres la
question reste ouverte et donc monsieur
le ministre je crois que c'est notre
responsabilité vous comme nous vous en
tant que ministre de l'Intérieur nous en
tant qu'au lieu locaux et parlementaire
pour ceux qui sont là mais que nous
sommes aussi parfois élus locaux
départementaux régionaux municipaux
d'apporter une réponse à cette question
qui reste ouverte il nous faut
absolument trouver une alternative si
c'est pas le canadair c'est autre chose
et dans quel délai on peut le trouver
parce que les agents et les hommes et
les femmes sur le terrain en grandement
besoin
merci Monsieur Bourget vous verrez dans
le rapport que nous avons commis au mois
de mai les constats que vous évoquez ont
été également faits madame
l'herbier puis ma belle retti après le
ministre
moi j'aimerais bien monsieur le ministre
d'avoir une petite précision concernant
le coup de du retour au pays parce que
en fin de compte celui qui repart
volontairement il paye son voyage celui
qui est expulsé écoute très cher
puisqu'il faut qu'il soit accompagné
comment on peut savoir avant à l'avance
pour organiser quand même une prévision
au niveau du cou de de ce que va coûter
justement le retour au pays
parce que c'est quand même important
moment de merci de budget
oui alors c'est pour aller dans votre
sens monsieur le ministre
j'aimerais beaucoup qu'on puisse trouver
les solutions concernant les titres des
séjours pour les personnes qui
travaillent pour leur facilité justement
une récupération plus simple parce
qu'ils sont obligés de prendre congé et
quelquefois et bien ça leur pose
problème donc pour ceux qui travaillent
facilité le renouvellement des titres de
séjour et deuxième question vous avez
parlé de doubler les places en crabe
mais en crabe il me semble qu'on y reste
90 jours et que fait-on de ces personnes
après
bien pas d'autres questions c'est le
ministre
bien alors pour venir bon monsieur
Bourgier je suis d'accord avec vous je
ne peux rien dire que je suis d'accord
puisque j'ai essayé de montrer que c'est
ce qu'on va essayer de changer donc sur
la façon dont les films numériques
existent vous êtes parfaitement raison
avec parfois des trafics vous avez
parfaitement raison également puis je
pense qu'il faut qu'on change notre
façon de faire en nous concentrant sur
les personnes qui méritent qu'on
s'attarde de sur eux c'est parce qu'ils
viennent d'arriver sur le territoire
national et qu'on doit contrôler leur
capacité à s'intégrer à parler français
à respecter lors de la République soit
parce qu'on doit suivre les auqtf et pas
embêter tous les autres donc je suis
d'accord et sur la sécurité civile je
reviens pas vous avez parfaitement
raison Et si vous étiez là d'ailleurs je
crois pour discours du président de la
République il a parlé longuement je
pourrais faire moins long et moins bien
que lui donc je vous renvoie un discours
l'excent discours du président de la
République la question qui se pose sur
l'écran
nous ne sommes pas obligés de mettre les
gens dans des centres de rétention
administratifs pour les éloigner il y a
plusieurs types d'autres
types pardon de façon différente il y a
des assignations à résidence il y a des
LRA c'est-à-dire dans des chambres
d'hôtels par exemple dans des
commissariats dans des brigades de
gendarmerie dans des prisons et puis il
y a des centres de rétention
administratifs qu'est-ce qu'on fait au
bout de 90 jours ou avant parce que
avant il peut être libéré parce que le
juge de liberté de la détention est
considérer que nous les mettions
indument dans un centre de rétention ça
arrive peu mais ça peut arriver et bien
nous mettons en place alors soit on
arrivait à les expulser à peu près
aujourd'hui on est plutôt bien situé
puisqu'on est à plus de 50% des gens
qu'on met en craint qu'on arrive à
expulser dans les deux trois mois ce qui
est une bonne amélioration des choses
sachant qu'aujourd'hui 90% des gens qui
sont en train sont des soit fish S soit
des gens qui ont des grands délinquants
on ne met quasiment plus encras de
manière extrêmement
minoritaire des personnes qui te posent
aucun problème à l'ordre public que ceux
qu'on met en crasse et rend les gens les
plus difficiles à éloigner
si on n'arrive pas à aller expulser dans
les trois mois qui suivent on les a
signé à résidence ils font des pointages
au commissariat parfois les policiers
gardent leur maison ou leur appartement
ou la chambre d'hôtel où ils sont donc
on continue à les surveiller bien
évidemment parfois on utilise des
techniques de géolocalisation ou
d'écoute lorsqu'ils qui sont les plus
dangereux parce que la loi nous le
permet donc on continue à les suivre on
les suit pas dans un centre de rétention
nous on préfère les suivre ensemble de
rétention problème c'est qu'on ne peut
pas allonger cette durée de rétention
c'est une directive européenne puisque
la durée de la durée de tension n'est
pas une peine complémentaire c'est une
peine privation liberté en attendant
l'expulsion donc on pourrait toujours
imaginer 10 jours de plus ou 20 jours de
moins mais ça changerait pas
fondamentalement grand chose au système
notre capacité notre capacité à obtenir
le laisser passer consulaire pour ces
personnes c'est la capacité qu'à le CRA
de Lyon
de Coquelles
de Lesquin de de se mettre d'accord avec
le consulat y pour pouvoir avoir le
laisser passer pour que les gens
puissent partir en temps voulu et donc
c'est un travail très important à faire
avec les consulats et donc un travail
diplomatique très important à faire pour
revenir à la question
de Madame de madame Jourdain
d'abord il y a un truc qui change
profondément dans le campus dans la loi
qu'on vous propose c'est que c'est pas
l'employeur qui demande la
régularisation c'est l'employé ça c'est
quand même très capital parce que ça
évite l'exploitation et c'est évite la
filière justement c'est aujourd'hui que
la filière d'immigration illégale se
construit puisque l'employeur en fait
dans notre droit ne peut pas embaucher
de personnes sans papiers mais dans le
fait il le fait et il dit au bout d'un
certain temps je demande moi je fais une
attestation et je dis à l'employé x
allez voir la préfecture grâce à mon
attestation d'employeur vous pourrez
être régularisé c'est quelque chose
bizarre de notre droit de dire
l'entreprise n'a pas le droit d'employer
sans papiers mais seul entrepreneur a le
droit de demander la réalisation du
travailleur sans papier qu'il a embauché
c'est ça qui crée la filière des
migration d'aujourd'hui c'est ce que
nous proposons cette changer les choses
c'est dire que l'employeur il ne dira
plus rien il discutera par branche avec
l'État et avec le Parlement pour dire
c'est quoi les métiers en tension on se
met d'accord sur la restauration par la
restauration sur le terrible à
l'hôtellerie l'agriculture par
l'agriculture pas l'agriculture on sait
tous mais vous savez bien qu'il y a des
secteurs qui ne fonctionnent pas s'il y
a pas des migrations
c'est un fait d'ailleurs c'est je vais
pas vous faire le procès de dire que
parfois ce qui intervient la télévision
contre les le projet du gouvernement et
sont les mêmes parlementaires qui me
font demande de papier pour des
personnes qui doivent travailler dans
les entreprises de leur circonscription
donc j'encourage chacun à être cohérent
dans ces demandes individuelles avec ces
positions politiques parce que
simplement on a connu tous des chaînes
d'entreprises qui disent on a besoin de
personnes qui ne travaillent chez nous
donc la question de savoir c'est encore
une fois des consultations que nous
faisons est-ce qu'on part du principe
qu'il faut une main d'oeuvre étrangère
en France ou pas
si oui laquelle dans quelles conditions
pour quel secteur
et l'employé lui c'est parce qu'il
viendra travailler dans un métier en
tension qu'il aura son titre de séjour
d'un an et pas parce qu'il est sur le
sol national qu'il a travaillé dans une
entreprise qui n'a rien avec le métier
de plateformes de livraison de repas
dotellerie de restauration qui
aujourd'hui ne sont pas dans les
intentions et qui demande la
régularisation et qu'on leur donne donc
on inverse totalement la charge de la
preuve pour lutter justement contre
l'immigration illégale puisque nous
créons mais si c'est aujourd'hui qu'on
crée une immigration légale mais c'est
un fait l'immigration inégale et les
créer toute la journée par des gens qui
embauchent des personnes sans papiers et
au bout de trois ans quatre ans c'est
même vrai madame la créatrice que vous
pouvez créer une auto-entreprise sur le
site vous pouvez le faire à l'expérience
je l'ai faite notons entreprise sans me
justifier de vos papiers avec des alias
et voici comment des gens créer une
auto-entreprise en France paye la
fiscalité paye des cotisations sont
embauchés par une plateforme de
livraison de repas ou de conduite de
personnes et au bout de trois ans vous
produisent des feuilles
d'autres entreprises et dit mais c'est
Bercy qui m'a donné mon papier il y a
trois ans comme quoi je pouvais
travailler et ce monsieur n'a jamais été
quelqu'un de de régulariser sur le
Centre national et c'est comme ça qu'on
en est à faire de la circulaire valse
c'est-à-dire à régulariser des gens de
fait parce que ça fait des années des
années des années des années qui sont là
qui payent des impôts dans une profite
pas de la solidarité qui paye des
cotisations sans jamais être protégées
socialement mais qu'on ne peut pas
expulser puisque ça fait 5 ans 6 ans 7
ans et quand ils vont voir le juge il
est Monsieur et bien sympathique mise à
l'intérieur là mais l'administration
française ça fait 7 ans qu'elle accepte
que ce monsieur il est des fiches de
paie et là vous retrouvez très bizarre
bon donc nous on change complètement la
charge de la preuve on dit c'est plus un
employeur de régulariser c'est un
employé de le faire après vous êtes donc
trois types de personnes soit la
personne arrive en France pour
travailler
dans ce cas là vous avez tout à fait
raison il existe un certain nombre de
titres de séjour mais pas de métier de
titre de séjour dîner tient en tension
et en tout cas la liste n'est pas
complète donc le premier débat qu'on
doit avoir c'est quelle liste de métiers
en tension et en effet quelle personne
est à l'extérieur et vient travailler en
France dans la culture dans l'hôtellerie
ou que sais-je deuxième hypothèse cette
personne est en France
alors ça dépend ce que vous appelez
irrégulier madame la sénatrice mais un
irrégulier c'est par exemple quelqu'un
qui vient avec un titre d'étudiant c'est
l'exemple que prenait cette horlogie qui
fait un an qui passe au cap de
pâtisserie voilà je sais pas où médecin
et qui trouve un emploi
parce que la personne d'à côté n'arrive
pas à l'embaucher le boulanger qui a
besoin de la pâtissier enfin fond de la
campagne ou le cabinet médical du coin
où les pas de Tourcoing qui dit bon ben
voilà madame vous êtes étudiante en
infirmière infirmière c'est très
intéressant nous on cherche des gens
pour travailler notre EHPAD cette
personne va demander un titre de séjour
pour travailler mais elle a été
régulière le temps qu'elle le demande
elle est venue en tant qu'étudiante
elle va dire je veux moi j'ai une
promesse d'embauche à l'EHPAD de
Tourcoing ils ont besoin de moi ils
trouvent personne d'autre et je demande
d'être embauché que lui répond
administration française repartez chez
vous madame demandez du consulat
d'Annaba en Algérie ou de d'Ottawa et on
vous écrira qui pense à son que cette
personne fait ça c'est l'hypocrisie
totale cette personne de repart pas
travail au black quand elle peut être
j'espère pas dans les EHPAD de Tourcoing
mais vous voyez ce que je veux dire
ailleurs on attend on dit dit rien à
imite on te fait même des faux papiers
ça c'est pour les plus élaborés ou
inscris-toi sur le nom de ta cousine ou
ton cousin qui lui est légal en secteur
international et au bout de deux ans je
te fais ton papier je reviens ma
première hypothèse et va demander la
régularisation nous ce qu'on dit c'est
quand il y aura des métiers en tension
on acceptera effectivement mais on peut
mettre un quota on peut mettre la liste
des métiers tout ça est ouvert à
discussion que ces personnes viennent
que pour ce job pour lequel elle va
embaucher pendant un an renouvelable
parce qu'aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui se
passe quand personne au bout de deux
trois ans démontre qu'elle a été
embauchée de manière indu mais avec des
fiches de paye des vrais fiches de paie
on est obligé de la régulariser non pas
en tant qu'infirmière qui travaille dans
l'EHPAD mais en tant que Madame X pour
tout le long de son séjour qui est très
long sur le territoire national c'est le
repas d'elle-même dans son pays c'est
comme ça que vous créez des fier
d'immigration c'est pas en faisant ce
que nous proposons et après 3e man c'est
une proposition il y a une odeur d'asile
un moment d'asile ils ont le droit de
travailler après six mois de demande
d'asile sur le secteur national ça c'est
le droit et après il y a des vendeurs
d'asile dont on sait à coup sûr qu'on va
leur donner l'asile les femmes yesidi
100% des femmes isidiques qui demandent
de l'asile en France c'est normal elles
ont l'asile
des personnes qui sont persécutées tous
les Afghans qu'on a fait revenir parce
qu'ils ont aidé la France et ils ont été
très nombreux on sait qu'on leur donnera
l'asile à la fin simplement pendant un
an ils ne peuvent pas travailler
est-ce qu'on peut pas se dire quand on
est sûr de donner la protection à
quelqu'un que en plus ils ont un métier
ils sont médecins afghan ils sont
infirmières ils sont ce que vous
souhaitez on vous donne un titre
temporaire d'un an c'est pas un titre de
10 ans c'est pas une naturalisation d'un
an en attendant votre demande d'asile
vous pouvez travailler le travail c'est
quand même la meilleure preuve de
l'intégration ou alors je ne sais pas
quelle est la France bon de dire voilà
on vous donne ce titre temporaire et si
jamais vous n'avez pas votre titre
définitif évidemment vous le reprend la
question de discuter d'autre chose mais
il y a un certain nombre de métiers dont
on a besoin de vous c'est bête qu'un
médecin afghan ne puisse pas travailler
à l'hôpital public français au moment où
on attend qu'il a été pourchassé par les
talibans il s'agit pas de le faire pour
tous les étrangers s'agit pas de le
faire pour tous les demandeurs d'asile
on n'a jamais dit ça s'agit de savoir si
on est d'accord pour avancer vers sa
disposition en tout cas c'est une
proposition certes innovante c'est ce
que font la quasi intégralité des pays
qui nous entourent a commencé par
l'Allemagne
et en même temps on ne crée pas de droit
nouveau pour ces personnes faut-il
lister les métiers en tension et que le
Parlement chaque année vote sur cette
liste c'est une discussion qu'on ouvre à
la discussion politique faut-il mettre
des quotas pour dire on n'a pas besoin
de plus de 500 médecins par an pourquoi
pas on peut mettre un certain nombre de
connard on a plein de discussions à
faire mais en tout cas elle est le
contraire me semble-t-il de la de la
régularisation
telle qu'on malheureusement nous la
pratiquons aujourd'hui le fait est
qu'aujourd'hui vous savez on entre 600
000 et 900 000 étrangers en situation
irrégulière en France et quel que soit
les gouvernements j'ai constaté que ça
avait pas beaucoup changé donc il faut
bien qu'on prenne le taureau par la
corne et qu'on se dise qu'il y a bien
des filières inacceptables qui créent
des non régularisables non expulsables
et c'est bien nous qui le créons par
notre droit trop long des recours trop
nombreux et une hypocrisie
capitalistique un peu forte quand même
parce que je veux aussi dire que le
patronat une part de responsabilité
lorsqu'ils font travailler les
travailleurs étrangers et nous leur
disons si vous les faites venir comment
vous les loger comment vous leur donnez
des de langue comment vous leur
permettez de vivre et s'intégrer moi si
vous devez résumer la philosophie de
notre projet de loi c'est qu'on doit
aider les gens qui veulent s'intégrer et
travailler dans notre pays et on doit
expulser les personnes qui se comportent
mal et qui ne respectent pas les règles
de notre pays je pense que moi de mon
maigravi le bon sens des Français va
avec avec ses propositions enfin Madame
l'herbier évoque combien ça coûte de
renvoyer des personnages me pose une
colle je veux bien lui détailler le
sujet pour la prochaine fois ce qui est
certain c'est que ça coûte un montant
important j'avais lu quelque part que
c'était si on additionnait tout y
compris le temps passé par les policiers
aux frontières pour garder la personne
et pour l'expulser quelques milliers
d'euros plus de 10000 euros parfois pour
les personnes les plus les plus longues
à expulser
13000 euros entre 12 et 13000 euros je
chiffre de 10000 mais effectivement
entre 12 et 13000 euros on compte tous
un coût complet bon
moins d'autant les gens passent sur
notre territoire moins ça coûte par
définition donc la rapidité d'exécution
pour nous est évidemment très très
importante alors nous on paye beaucoup
de choses on peut payer le billet
d'avion on peut faire aussi le retour
aidé
je rappelle que c'est sous la présidence
de Nicolas Sarkozy qu'on a été inventé
le on donnait de l'argent pour que je
reparte il y a eu quelques abus parce
que parfois il revenait bon ça peut
arriver mais on a changé les choses le
fait que vous pouvez additionner
évidemment mais je sais que vous les
connaissez bien désormais c'est des
cartes prépayées qu'on ne peut débloquer
que dans le pays dans lequel est arrivé
et évidemment il y a une interdiction de
retour désormais sur le territoire
national pour éviter cela moi je ne
pense pas que l'augmentation des crédits
pour les retours aidés soit une bonne
chose parce que ça donne une impression
de récompense la personne qui est venue
irrégulièrement sur le territoire
national en revanche il est des gens qui
viennent en France qui doivent repartir
qui ne savent pas comment repartir parce
qu'ils sont eux-mêmes très éloignés de
la vie administrative vous savez il
faudrait pas sous-estimer je terminerai
par là monsieur le Président que ce qui
arrive à nos concitoyens les plus
éloignés de la vie
administrative arrive aux étrangers il y
avait un calcul madame l'herbier dans
une ville que vous connaissez bien qui
m'avait été donnée par la poste quand je
suis devenu maire 22% des personnes qui
habitent et ma commune n'ouvraient pas
un courrier écrit à l'ordinateur sur
l'étiquette pour l'instant sans doute
que c'était une facture et faisons la
procrastination et quand vous allez
faire du portable dans les quartiers
populaires vous voyez bien de quoi je
parle il y a des quick ne sont pas
ouverts parce qu'on a peur de la de
l'administration ou de l'annonce qu'elle
va faire incompréhensible il est certain
que si vous êtes étranger prenons de ne
pas de recul imaginons que soyons en
trajet dans la soyons somalien et
ivoirien guinéens nous arrivons sur le
territoire français pour plein de
raisons et on vous dit voilà vous n'êtes
pas bien bienvenue et voici je vous
délivre une auqtf est-ce que vous avez
déjà vu ce que c'était qu'une qtf c'est
pas super simple à comprendre surtout
quand vous disez pas et parlez pas
français
donc qu'est-ce qui se passe en général
si c'est pas l'État notamment par le
dire de Luffy qui aide les personnes à
expliquer ce qui se passe et leur dire
monsieur vous avez pas de compte
bancaire comment je fais un billet
d'avion quand on n'a pas de compte
bancaire il y avait aussi des moments où
les gens ils sont un peu dans
l'incapacité ils sont pas tous pervers
auprès de l'idée comment je vais tricher
avec l'administration il y a plein de
gens je crois on n'est pas capable de
les accompagner correctement et donc il
faut aussi que nous réfléchissons tout
en étant très ferme dans la reconduite à
comment on les raccompagne il y a plein
de gens qui ne posent aucun problème à
leur public mais qui sont un peu paumés
et qui vivent dans un entrelat et
parfois pris en main par quelques
officines qui elles ne veulent pas
appliquer les lois de la République mais
explique aux gens comment on ne les
applique pas ça c'est un autre un autre
sujet donc si on veut éviter que les
passeurs s'en occupent ou quelques
associations les immenses majorité
d'entre elles sont très humanitaires et
nous aident mais quelques-unes
organisent la vie pour lutter contre la
République je pense qu'on a aussi nous
beaucoup à améliorer et après il y a
ceux qui vont tricher qui vont vouloir
duper qui vont faire des actes de
délinquance il faut qu'on soit très
ferme il faut qu'ils aillent dans les
cras il faut qu'on c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que dans le même projet de
loi j'ai proposé qu'on mette fin à
toutes les réserves dans le public la
fameuse double peine qui avait été jadis
je le rappelle supprimer et aujourd'hui
je résume une nouvelle fois la solution
cette gentil avec les gentille gentil
avec ceux qui travaillent et être
méchant avec les méchants c'est à dire
ceux qui commettent des actes de
délinquance j'ai tendance à penser
depuis que je suis mise à l'intérieur et
quand j'étais mère moi-même qu'on est
parfois un peu gentil avec les méchants
et qu'on est parfois méchant un peu avec
les gens
bien merci monsieur le ministre mais
nous aurons un débat approfondie et
intéressant sur l'immigration et je
pense encore plus large que celui que
nous venons d'avoir et
j'ai lu des choses intéressantes dans
votre
article de presse récent j'ai vu
notamment que les propositions qui
avaient été faites par le Sénat voté par
le Sénat serait reprise ces gages d'un
travail que nous allons engager
maintenant parce que j'en terminerai par
là l'enjeu c'est bien sûr des mesures
concrètes comme les vocons maintenant
mais c'est d'abord la définition de la
politique migratoire du pays
quelles sont les grandes objectifs quels
sont les grandes stratégies et après on
fera le droit en déclinera mais je crois
que c'est un des enjeux premier ce sera
aussi celui-ci en tous les cas merci
pour toutes les précisions que vous avez
apportées à l'occasion cette édition je
lève donc la séance et vous remercie
monsieur le ministre